whatever reality is
it's not what you see
what you see
is is just
an adaptive fiction
the following is a conversation with
donald hoffman professor of cognitive
sciences at uc irvine focusing his
research on evolutionary psychology
visual perception and consciousness
he's the author of over 120 scientific
papers on these topics and his most
recent book titled the case against
reality why evolution hid the truth from
our eyes
i think some of the most interesting
ideas in this world like those of donald
hoffman's attempt to shake the
foundation of our understanding of
reality and thus
they take a long time to internalize
deeply
so proceed with caution
questioning the fabric of reality can
lead you to either
madness or the truth and the funny thing
is you won't know which is which
this is the lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's donald
hoffman in your book the case against
reality why evolution hid the truth from
our eyes
you make the bold claim that the world
we see with our eyes is not real
it's not even an abstraction of
objective reality it is completely
detached from
uh objective reality
can you explain this idea right so this
is a theorem from evolution by natural
selection so
the technical question that i and my
team asked was
what is the probability that
natural selection would shape sensory
systems to see true properties of
objective reality
and to our surprise we found that the
answer is precisely zero except for one
one kind of structure we can go into if
you want to but for for any generic
structure that you might think the world
might have a total order a topology
metric
the probability is precisely zero that
natural selection would shape any
sensory system
of any organism to see any aspect of
objective reality so in that sense
uh what we're seeing is
what we need
to see
to stay alive long enough to reproduce
so in other words we're seeing what we
need to guide adaptive behavior full
stop
so
the evolutionary process the process
that took us from the origin of life on
earth to the humans that we are today
that process does not maximize
for truth to maximizes for fitness as
you say fitness beats truth
and fitness does not have to be
connected to truth is the claim
and that's where you have an approach
towards zero of probability that we
have evolved
human cognition
human consciousness whatever it is the
magic that makes our mind work
evolved
not for its ability to see the truth of
reality but its ability to survive in
the environment that's exactly right so
most of us intuitively think that
surely
the way that evolution
will make our senses more fit
is to make them tell us more truths or
at least the truths we need to know
about objective reality the truths we
need in our niche
that's the standard view and it was the
view i took i mean that's sort of what
we were
taught or just even assume it's just
sort of like the intelligent assumption
that we would all make
but
we don't have to just wave our hands the
evolution of natural selection is a
mathematically precise theory uh john
maynard smith in the 70s
created evolutionary game theory and
we have evolutionary graph theory and
even genetic algorithms that we can use
to study this and so we don't have to
wave our hands it's it's a matter of
theorem and proof and or simulation
before you get the theorems and proofs
and
a couple graduate students of mine
justin mark and brian marion did some
wonderful simulations that tipped me off
that there was something going on here
and then i went to a mathematician
chaitan prakash and manish singh and
some other friends of mine chris fields
and but chaitan was the real
mathematician in behind all this and
he's proved several theorems that
uniformly indicate that
with one exception which has to do with
probability measures
um
there's no uh
the probability of zero the the reason
there's an exception for probability
measures so-called
sigma algebras or or um
sigmative classes
is that for any scientific theory
uh
there is the assumption that that needs
to be made that
the whatever
structure the
whatever probabilistic structure the
world may have
is not
unrelated to the probabilistic structure
of our perceptions if they were
completely unrelated then no science
would be possible
so and so this is technically the
the
map from reality to our senses has to be
a so-called measurable map has to
preserve sigma algebras but that means
it could be infinite to one and it could
collapse all sorts of
event information but other than that
there's there's no requirement in
standard evolutionary theory
for
fitness payoff functions for example to
preserve any specific structures of
objective reality so you can ask the
technical question this is one of the
avenues we took
um
if you look at all the fitness payoffs
from
whatever
world structure you might want to
imagine so a world with say a total
order on it
so it's got end states and they're
totally ordered and then you can have
a set of maps from that world into a set
of payoffs say from zero to a thousand
or whatever you want your payoffs to be
and you can just literally count all the
payoff functions
and just do the combinatorics and count
them then you can ask a precise question
how many of those payoff functions
preserve the total order if that's what
you live or how many preserve the
topology
and you just count them and divide so so
the number that are homomorphisms
versus the total number and then take
the limit as the number
of states in the world and the number of
payoff values goes very large and when
you do that you get zero every time okay
you've
there's a million things to ask here but
first of all
just in case
uh people are not familiar with your
work
let's sort of linger on the big bold
statement here
which is the thing we see with our eyes
is not
some kind of limited window into reality
it is completely detached from reality
likely completely detached from reality
you're saying 100 likely
okay
so none of this is real
in the way we think is real in the way
we have this intuition there's um
like this table
is some kind of abstraction but
underneath it all there's atoms and
there's an entire century of physics
that describes the functioning of those
atoms and the quarks that make them up
there's
many nobel prizes
about particles and fields and all that
kind of stuff that
uh slowly builds up to something that's
perceivable to us both with our eyes
with our different senses as this
table
then there's also ideas of chemistry
that over layers of abstraction from dna
to embryos the cells
that make
the human body
so all of that
is not real
it's a real experience and it's a real
adaptive set of
perceptions so it's an adaptive set of
perceptions full stop
we want to think perceptions are real so
so their perceptions are real as
perceptions right they are we are having
our perceptions
but we've assumed that there's uh a
pretty tight relationship between
our perceptions and reality if i look up
and see
the moon then there is something that
exists in space and time that uh matches
um what i perceive and
all i'm saying is that if you
take evolution by natural selection
seriously
then
that is precluded that our perceptions
are there they're there to guide
adaptive behavior
full stop they're not there to show you
the truth in fact the way i think about
it is they're there to hide the truth
because the truth is too complicated
it's just like if you're trying to you
know
use your laptop to write an email
right what you're doing is toggling
voltages in the computer but good luck
trying to do it that way that's
the reason why we have a user interface
is because we don't want to know that
quote unquote truth the diodes and
resistors all that that terrible
hardware if you had to know all that
truth
it would your friends wouldn't hear from
you
so you
so what evolution gave us was
perceptions that guide adaptive behavior
and part of that process it turns out
means hiding the truth and giving you
eye candy
so
what's the difference between hiding the
truth
and forming abstractions
uh
layers upon layers of abstractions over
these of our low level voltages and
transistors and
chips and
programming languages from assembly to
python that then leads you to be able to
have an interface like chrome where you
open up another set of javascript and
html
uh programming languages that lead you
to have a graphical user interface on
which you can then send your friends an
email
is that completely detached
from the zeros and ones
that are firing away inside the computer
it's not
of course when i talk about the user
interface on your desktop
um there's this whole
sophisticated
backstory to it right that that the
hardware and the software that's
allowing that to happen
evolution doesn't tell us the backstory
right so the theory of evolution is not
going to be adequate to tell you
what is that backstory it's going to say
that
whatever reality is and that's the
interesting thing it says whatever
reality is you don't see it
you see a user interface but it doesn't
tell you
what that user interface is how it's
built
right now we can we can try to look at
certain aspects of the interface but
already we're going to look at that and
go real okay before i would look at
neurons and i was assuming i was seeing
something that was
at least partially true
and now i'm realizing it could be like
looking at the pixels on my desktop
or icons on my desktop and good luck you
know going from that to the data
structures and then the voltages and i
mean good luck
there's just no way so what's
interesting about this is that our
scientific theories
are
precise enough and rigorous enough to
tell us certain limits
but and even the limits of the theories
themselves
but they're not
going to tell us what the next move is
and that's where scientific creativity
comes in
so the stuff that i'm saying here for
example um is not alien to physicists
the physicists are saying
precisely the same thing that space time
is doomed we've assumed that space time
is fundamental we've assumed that for
for several centuries and it's been very
useful so all the things that you were
mentioning the particles and all the
work that's been done that's all been
done in space time but now physicists
are saying space time is doomed there's
no such thing
as space time fundamentally
in the laws of physics
and
that comes actually out of
gravity together with quantum field
theory it just comes right out of it
it's it's it's a theorem of of those two
theories put together
but it doesn't tell you what's behind it
so the physicists are know that their
their best theories
einstein's gravity and quantum field
theory put together
entail that space-time cannot be
fundamental and therefore particles in
space-time cannot be fundamental
they're just irreducible representations
of the symmetries of space time that's
what they are so we have so space time
so we put the two together we put
together what the physicists are
discovering and we can talk about how
they do that and then we the new
discoveries from evolution of natural
selection both of these discoveries are
really in the last 20 years
and what both are saying is um spacetime
has had a good ride
it's been very useful reductionism has
been useful but it's over and it's time
for us to go beyond when you say
spacetime is doomed is it the space is
the is the is it the time is it the very
hard-coded specification of four
dimensions
um
or are you specifically referring to the
kind of uh
perceptual domain that humans operate in
which is space time you think like
there's a 3d
um
like our world is three dimensional and
time progresses forward therefore three
dimensions plus one for d what uh what
what exactly do you mean by space-time
what do you mean by space-time is doomed
great great so this is by the way not my
quote this is from for example nema or
kanye hamed
at the institute for advanced study at
princeton ed whitten
also there david gross
nobel prize winner so this is not just
something the cognitive scientists this
is what the physicists are saying yeah
the physicists are space-time uh
skeptics
we are they're saying that and i can say
exactly why
they think it's doomed but what they're
saying is that you know because your
question was what what aspect of space
time what are we talking about here it's
both space and time they're union into
space time as an einstein's theory
that's doomed
and
they're they're basically saying that
even quantum theory this is with neymar
connie ahmed especially so the
hilbert spaces will not be fundamental
either so that that
the notion of hilbert space which is
really critical to
quantum field theory quantum information
theory uh that's not going to figure in
the fundamental
new laws of physics so what they're
looking for is some new mathematical
structures beyond space-time
beyond
you know einstein's four-dimensional
space-time or
supersymmetric version
geometric algebra signature two comma
four kind of there are different ways
you can represent it but they're finding
new structures and then by the way
they're succeeding now they're finding
they found something called the
amplitude this is nema and his
colleagues the
the cosmological polytope these are so
there are these like
polytopes these polyhedra in in
multi-dimensions generalizations of
simplices
that are coding
for
for example the scattering amplitudes of
processes in the large hadron collider
and other other colliders so they're
finding that if they let go space-time
completely
they're finding new ways of computing
these scattering amplitudes that turn
literally billions of terms into one
term
when you do it in space and time because
it's the wrong framework it's it's it's
just a user interface from that's now
from the evolutionary point of view it's
just user interface it's not a deep
insight into the nature of reality so
it's missing deep symmetry something
called a dual conformal symmetry which
turns out to be true of the scattering
data but you can't see it in space-time
and it's making the comp the
computations way too complicated because
you're trying to compute all the loops
and feynman diagrams and all the
finement integrals so see the feynman
approach to the scattering amplitudes is
trying to enforce two critical
properties of space time locality and
unitarity
and so by when you enforce those you get
all these loops and multiple you know
different levels of loops and for each
of those you have to add new terms to
your computation but when you
do it outside of space time
you don't have the notion of unitarity
you don't have the notion of locality
you have something deeper and is
capturing some symmetries that are
actually true of the data
and but then when you look at the
geometry of the facets of these
polytopes
then certain of them will code for
unitarity and locality so it actually
comes out of the structure of these deep
polytubes so what we're finding is
there's this whole new world now
beyond space-time
that is making explicit symmetries that
are true of the data that cannot be seen
in space-time
and that is turning the computations
from billions of terms to one or two or
a handful of terms so we're getting
insights into symmetries and we're and
all of a sudden the math is becoming
simple because we're not doing something
silly we're not adding up all these
loops in space time we're doing
something far deeper but they don't know
what this world is about also
you know they're in an interesting
position
where we know that space time is doomed
and not i should probably tell you why
it's doomed what they're saying about
why it's doomed but but they need a
flashlight to look beyond space-time
what what flashlight are we going to use
to look into the dark beyond space time
because einstein's theory and quantum
theory can't tell us what's beyond them
all they can do is tell us that when you
put us together space time
is doomed at 10 to the minus 33
centimeters 10 to the minus 43 seconds
beyond that
space time doesn't even make sense it
just has no operational definition
so but it doesn't tell you what's beyond
and so they're they're just looking for
deep structures like guessing
it's really fun so these really
brilliant guys
generic brilliant men and women who are
doing this work
physicists are making guesses about
these structures informed guesses
because they're trying to ask well okay
what deeper structure could give us the
stuff that we're seeing in space time
but without certain commitments that we
have to make in space time like locality
and so they make these brilliant guesses
and of course most of the time you're
going to be wrong but once you get one
or two that start to pay off and then
you get some lucky breaks so they got a
lucky break back in 1986
a couple of mathematicians named park
and taylor
took the scattering amplitude for two
gluons coming in at high energy and four
gluons going out at low energy so that
kind of scattering thing so it's like
apparently for people who are into this
that's sort of something that happens so
often you need to be able to find it and
get rid of those because you already
know about that and you need to so you
needed to compute them it was billions
of terms
and they couldn't do it even for the
supercomputers couldn't do that for the
many billions or millions of times per
second they need to do it so they they
begged the experimentalists begged the
theorists please can you you got it and
so park and taylor took the billions of
terms hundreds of pages and
miraculous miraculously turned it into
nine
and then a little bit later they guessed
one term expression that turned out to
be equivalent so
billions of terms reduced to one term
the so-called famous park taylor formula
1986 and that was like okay where did
that come from what this is a pointer
into a deep realm
beyond space and time but but no one i
mean what can you do with it and they
thought maybe it was a one-off but then
other formulas started coming up and
then eventually neymar connie hamad and
his team found this thing called the
amplitude which really sort of captures
the whole
a big part of the whole balox
i'm sure they would say no there's
plenty more to do so so i won't say they
did it all by any means they're looking
at the cosmological polytope as well so
what's remarkable to me
is that
two pillars of modern science
quantum field through with gravity on
the one hand
and evolution by natural selection on
the other
just in the last 20 years have very
clearly said
space time has had a good run
reductionism has been a fantastic
methodology so we had a great ontology
of space time a great methodology of
reductionism
now it's time for a new trick
but now you need to go deeper and and
show but by the way this doesn't mean we
throw away everything we've done not by
a long shot
every new idea that we come up with
beyond space time must project precisely
into space time and it better give us
back everything that we know and love in
space time or generalizations
or it's not going to be taken seriously
and it shouldn't be so so we have a
strong constraint on whatever we're
going to do beyond space-time it needs
to project into space-time and whatever
this deeper theory is it may not itself
have evolution by natural selection this
may not be part of this deeper realm but
when we take the whatever that thing is
beyond space-time and projected into
space-time it has to look like evolution
by natural selection or it's wrong
so so that's
so that's a strong constraint on this
work so even the evolution
by natural selection and uh
quantum field theory
could be interfaces into something that
that doesn't look anything like
like you mentioned i mean it's
interesting to think that evolution
might be
a very crappy interface into something
much deeper that's right they're both
telling us that the framework that
you've had can only go so far and it has
to stop and there's something beyond and
that framework the very framework that
is space and time itself now of course
evolution by natural selection is not
telling us
about like einstein's relativistic
spaces that was another question you
asked a little bit earlier it's telling
us more about our perceptual space and
time
which um we have used as the basis for
creating first a newtonian space versus
time
as a mathematical extension of our
perceptions and then einstein then took
that and extended it even further so the
relationship between what evolution is
telling us what the physicists are
telling us is that in some sense the
newton and einstein
space time
are formulated
as sort of
rigorous extensions of our perceptual
space
um making it mathematically rigorous and
laying out the symmetries that that they
find there so that's sort of the
relationship between them so it's the
perceptual space time that evolution is
telling us
is just a user interface effectively
and then the physicists are finding that
even the mathematical extension of that
into the einsteinian formulation
has to be as well um not the final story
there's something deeper so let me ask
you about reductionism and interfaces
as we march forward from newtonian
physics
uh
to quantum mechanics
these are all
in your view interfaces
are we getting closer to objective
reality
how do we know
if these interfaces in the process of
science
the reason we like those interfaces is
because they're predictive of some
aspects strongly predictive about some
aspects of our reality
is that completely deviating from
our understanding of that reality or is
it helping us get closer and closer and
closer
well of course one critical constraint
on all of our theories is that they are
empirically tested and past
the experiments that we
have for them so so no one's arguing
against experiments being important and
wanting to test all of our our current
theories
and uh any new theories on that so
that's that's
that's all there
but
we have good reason to believe
that science will never get a theory of
everything
you know everything everything
everything everything right a final
theory of everything right
i think that my own take is for what
it's worth is that girdles in
completeness theorem
sort of points us in that direction that
even with mathematics
uh any finite accidentalization that's
sophisticated enough to be able to do
arithmetic
it's easy to show that there'll be
statements that are true that can't be
proven
can't be deduced from within that
framework
and if you add the new statements to
your axioms then there'll be always new
statements that are true but can't be
proven with a new axiom system
and
the best scientific theories
indian physics for example and also now
evolution are mathematical so our
theories are going to be they're going
to have their own assumptions
and um
they'll be mathematically precise and
they'll be theories perhaps of
everything except those assumptions
because the assumptions are
we say please grant me these assumptions
if you grant me these assumptions then i
can explain this other stuff
but so you have the assumptions that um
[Music]
are
like miracles as far as the theory is
concerned they're not explained they're
the starting points for explanation and
then you have the mathematical structure
of the theory itself which will have the
girdle limits
and so
my my take is that um reality whatever
it is is
always going to transcend
any
conceptual theory that we can come up
with there's always going to be mystery
at the edges
right uh contradictions and all that
kind of stuff okay
and truths
so there's an this idea that is brought
up in the financial space of uh
settlement of transactions
it's often talked about in
cryptocurrency especially
so you could do you know money cash is
not connected to
anything
uh it used to be connected to gold
to physical reality but then you can use
money to exchange uh to exchange value
to transact
uh so when it was on the gold standard
the money would represent some
stable
uh component of reality isn't it
more effective
to avoid things like hyperinflation
if we generalize that idea isn't it
better
to connect your
uh whatever we humans are doing in the
social interaction space with each other
isn't it better
from an evolutionary perspective to
connect it to some degree to reality so
that the the transactions are settled
with something that's universal as
opposed to us constantly operating in
something that's a complete illusion
isn't it easy to hyperinflate that
like when where you really deviate very
very far away
from
um
from the underlying reality or do you
not never get in trouble for this
can you just completely drift far far
away
from the underlying reality and never
get in trouble
that's a great question
on the financial side
there's two levels at least that we
could take your question one one is
strictly like evolutionary psychology of
financial systems um and that's that's
pretty interesting um and there the
decentralized idea that the d5 kind of
idea in cryptocurrencies
may make good sense from just an
evolutionary psychology point of view
having you know human nature being what
it is
putting a lot of
faith in a few central controllers
depends a lot on the
veracity of those and trustworthiness of
those few central controllers and we
have ample evidence time and again that
um that's often betrayed
so it makes good evolutionary sense i
would say to have a decentralized i mean
democracy is a step in that direction
right we're we don't we don't have a
monarch now telling us what to do we
decentralize things right because if the
monarch if you have marcus aurelius as
your emperor you're great if you have
nero
it's not so great and so we don't want
that so democracy is a step in that
direction but but i think the defy
thing is is an even bigger step and is
is going to even make the
democratization even even greater so so
that's one level also the fact that
power corrupts and absolute power
corrupts absolutely is also
an evolut a consequence of
evolution
right that's also a feature i think
right you can argue from the long span
of living organisms it's nice for power
to corrupt for you to it so
uh
mad men and women throughout history
might be useful to teach
us a lesson
we can learn from our negative example
right exactly right right
right so power does corrupt and i think
that
you can think about that again from an
evolutionary point of view
but i think that your question was a
little deeper when that was
is does the evolutionary
interface idea
sort of unhinge science from
from some kind of
important test for the theories right we
don't want it
doesn't mean that anything goes in
scientific theory but there's no
if there if we don't see the truth is
there no way to tether our theories and
test them and and i think
there there's no problem there we we can
only test things in terms of what we can
measure with our senses in space and
time so
we're going to have to continue to do
experiments and but we're going to re
we're going to understand a little bit
differently what those experiments are
we had thought that when we see
a pointer on a
some machine in a you know
an experiment that the machine exists
the pointer exists and the values exist
even when no one is looking at them and
that they're an objective truth and and
our best theories are telling us no the
pointers
pointers are just pointers
and that's what you have to rely on for
making your judgments
um but
um
that even the pointers themselves are
not
the objective reality
so and and i think girdle is telling us
that
not that um anything goes but
you know as you develop new axiom
systems you will find out what goes
within that axiom system
and what what testable predictions you
can make so i don't think we're we're
untethered we we continue to do
experiments what i think we
won't have that we want
is a conceptual understanding
that gives us a theory of everything
that's final and complete i i think that
this is
to put it another way this is job
security for scientists
our job will never be done is job
security for neuroscience
because
before we thought that when we looked in
the brain we saw neurons and neural
networks and
and uh you know action potentials and
and synapses and so forth and that's
that was it that that was the reality
now we have to reverse engineer that we
have to say what is beyond space time
what is going on what is a dynamical
system beyond space time that when we
project it into einstein space time
gives us things that look like neurons
and neural networks and synapses
that's so we have to reverse engineer so
there's going to be lots more work for
neuroscience it's going to be far more
complicated and difficult and
challenging but but that's wonderful
that's what we need to do we thought
neurons exist when they aren't perceived
and they don't in the same way that if i
show you when i say they don't exist i
should be very very concrete
if i draw on a piece of paper a little
sketch
of something that is called the necker
cube it's just a little line drawing of
a cube right on a flat piece of paper if
i execute it well and i show it to you
you'll see a 3d cube and you'll see it
flip sometimes you'll see one face in
front sometimes you'll see the other
face in front
but if i ask you know
which face is in front when you don't
look
you know
the answer is well neither face is in
front because there's no cube
this is a flat piece of paper yeah so
when you look at the piece of paper you
perceptually create the cube
and when you look at it then you fix one
face to be in front and one face to the
other so that's what i mean when i say
it doesn't exist space time itself is
like the cube it's a data structure that
your sensory systems construct whatever
your sensory systems mean now because we
now have to
even not even take that for granted but
there are perceptions that you construct
on the fly
and uh their data structures and the
computer sciences and you garbage
collect them when you don't need them so
you create them and garbage collect them
but is it possible that it's mapped well
in some concrete predictable way to
objective reality the sheet of paper
this two-dimensional space
or we can talk about
space-time
maps in some
way that we maybe don't yet understand
but will
one day understand
what that mapping is but it maps
reliably it is tethered in that way well
yes and and so the new theories that the
physicists are finding beyond spacetime
have that kind of tethering so they're
they show precisely how you start with
an amplitude and how you project this
high dimensional structure into
the four dimensions of space time
so there's a precise procedure that that
relates the two and
they're doing the same thing with the
cosmological polytopes so so they're the
they're the ones that are making the
most uh you know concrete and and fun
advances going beyond space time and
there they're they're tethering it right
they say this is precisely the
mathematical projection from this deeper
structure into space time
one thing i'll say about
as a non-physicist what that i find
interesting is that they're finding just
geometry but there's no notion of
dynamics
right now they're just finding these
static geometric structures
which is impressive i'm so i'm not
putting them down this is what they're
doing is unbelievably complicated and
brilliant and uh
adventurous although
it's all those things and beautiful
beautiful yeah from a human aesthetic
perspective because geometry is
beautiful it's it's absolutely and it's
f they're finding symmetries that are
true of the data that can't be seen in
space-time
but i'm looking for a theory beyond
space time
that's a dynamical theory
i would love to find and we can talk
about that at some point a theory of
consciousness in which
the dynamics of consciousness itself
will give rise to the geometry that the
physicists are finding beyond space time
if we can do that then we'd have a
completely different way of looking at
how consciousness is related to what we
call the brain or the physical world
more generally right right now
all of my brilliant colleagues well 99
of them are trying to
they're they're assuming space-time is
fundamental
they're assuming that particles are
fundamental
quarks gluons leptons and so forth
elements atoms and so forth are
fundamental and that therefore neurons
and brains are part of objective reality
and that somehow when you get matter
that's complicated enough
it will somehow
generate conscious experiences by its
functional properties or if you're pan
psychist maybe you in addition to the
physical properties of particles you add
your consciousness
property as well and then you have you
combine these physical and conscious
properties to get more complicated ones
but they're all doing it within space
time
all of the work that's being done on
consciousness and this relationship
to the brain is all assumed something
that our fit our best theories are
telling us is doomed space time why does
that particular assumption bother you
the most so you bring up space time
i mean that's just one
useful interface we've used for a long
time
uh surely there's other interfaces is
space time just the
one of the big ones that you
to build up people's intuition about the
fact that they just do assume a lot of
things strongly
or or it is is it in fact the
fundamental flaw in the way we see the
world
well everything else that we think we
know
are things in space time
sure and so
if you when you say space time is doomed
this is a shot to the heart yeah
of the whole
framework the whole conceptual framework
that we've had in science
not to the scientific method but to the
the fundamental ontology and also the
fundamental methodology the ontology of
spacetime and its contents
and the methodology of reductionism
which is that as we go to smaller
scales in space-time
we will find more and more fundamental
laws
and it's been very useful for
for the space and time for centuries
reductionism for centuries
but but now we realize that
that's over
reductionism is in fact dead
as is space time what exactly is
reductionism what is the process of
reductionism
that is different
than uh
some of the physicists that you
mentioned that are trying to think
trying to let go of the assumption of
space-time looking beyond isn't that
still trying to come up with a simple
model that explains this whole thing
isn't it still reducing
it's a wonderful question because it
really helps to clarify two different
notions which is scientific explanation
on the one hand
and a particular kind of scientific
explanation on the other which is the
reductionist so the reductionist
explanation is saying i will start with
with
things that are smaller in space-time
and therefore more fundamental where the
laws are more fundamental
so we go
uh to just smaller and smaller scales
whereas with
in science more generally we just say
like when einstein did the special
theory of relativity
he's saying let me have a couple
postulates i will assume that the speed
of light is universal for for all um
[Music]
observers
in uniform motion um and that the laws
of physics so i feel for for uniform
motion are are those
that's not a reductionist that those are
saying grant me these assumptions i can
build this entire
concept of space time out of it it's not
a reductionist thing you're not going to
smaller and smaller scales of space
you're you're coming up with these deep
deep principles same thing with this
theory of gravity
right it's the falling elevator idea
right so this is not a reductionist kind
of thing it's it's it's it's it's
something different so simplification
is a bigger thing than just reductionism
reductionism has been a particularly
useful kind of scientific explanation
for example in thermodynamics
right where the notion that we have of
heat some macroscopic thing like
temperature and heat
it turns out that neil boltzmann and
others
discover well hey you know if we go to
smaller and smaller scales we find these
things called molecules or atoms and if
we think of them as bouncing around
having some kind of energy then um what
we call heat is is a is really can be
reduced to to that
and and so that's a particularly useful
kind of
reduction is a useful kind of scientific
explanation that works within a range of
scales within space-time but we know now
precisely where that has to stop at 10
to the minus 33 centimeters and 10 to
the minus 43 seconds and i would be
impressed if it was 10 to the minus 33
trillion centimeters i'm not terribly
impressed at 10 to the minus 33
centimeters
[Laughter]
i don't even know how to comprehend
either of those numbers frankly uh do
just a small aside because i am
a computer science person i also find
cellular automator beautiful yes and uh
so you have somebody like
uh stephen wolfram who recently has been
very
excitedly exploring um
a proposal for a data structure that
could be
um the numbers that would make you a
little bit happier in terms of scale
because they're very very very very tiny
do you like this space of exploration
i'm really thinking letting go of space
time letting go of everything and trying
to think what kind of data structures
could be underneath this whole mess
that's right so if they're thinking
about these as outside of space-time
then that's that's what we have to do
that's what our best theories are
telling us you now have to think outside
of space-time now of course
i should
back up and say
we know that einstein
surpassed newton right but that doesn't
mean that there's not good work to do a
newton there's all sorts of newtonian
physics that takes us to the moon and so
forth and there's lots of good problems
that we want to solve with newtonian
physics the same thing will be true of
space-time we'll we'll still it's not
like we're going to stop using space
time we'll continue to do all sorts of
good work there but for for those
scientists who are really looking to
go deeper to actually find the next you
know just like what einstein did to
newton what what are we going to do to
einstein how do we get beyond einstein
and quantum theory to something deeper
then we have to actually let go and and
if we're going to do like this
a automata kind of approach
it's critical that it's not automata in
space-time it's automata prior to
space-time from which we're going to
show how space-time emerges if you're
doing automotive within space-time well
that might be a fun model but it's not
the radical new step that we need
yeah so the space time emerges from that
whatever system yeah like you're saying
it's
it's a dynamical system do we even have
an understanding what dynamical means
when we go beyond
when we start to think about dynamics
that could mean a lot of things
even causality could mean a lot of
things if if we
if we realize that everything is an
interface
like what how much do we really know is
an interesting question because you
brought up neurons i got to ask you and
another yet another tangent there's a
paper i remember a while ago looking at
called uh could a neuroscientist
understand a microprocessor and i just
enjoyed that thought experiment that
they provided which is they basically
it's a couple of uh neuroscientists eric
jonas and conrad cording
uh who
used the tools of neuroscience to
analyze
a microprocessor i saw a computer
computer chip now if we lesion it here
what happens and so forth and if you go
on lesion in the computer
it's very very clear that lesion
experiments on computers are not going
to give you a lot of insight into how it
works and also the measurement devices
and the kind of sort of just using the
basic approaches of neuroscience
collecting the data
trying to intuit about the underlying
function of it and that helps you
understand that
our scientific exploration of concepts
depending on the field
uh our are
maybe in the very very early stages
i wouldn't say it
leads us astray
perhaps it does sometimes but it's not a
uh
it's not anywhere close to some
fundamental mechanism that actually
makes a thing work i don't know if you
can sort of
comment on that in terms of using
neuroscience to understand the human
mind and
neurons
are we really far away potentially from
uh understanding in the way we
understand
the
transistors enough to be able to build a
computer so one one um
one thing about understanding is you can
understand for fun
the other one is
to understand so you could build
things
and and that's when you really have to
understand
uh exactly in fact what got me into the
field that i
at mit was um worked by david marr
on this very topic so david maher
was a professor at mit but he'd done his
phd in neuroscience studying just the
architectures of the brain but he
realized that his his work it was on the
cerebellum um
he he realized that his work
as as rigorous as it was
left him unsatisfied because he didn't
know what the cerebellum was for
yeah and and and why it had that
architecture and so he
he went to mit and he was in the ai lab
there and and uh
he said he had this three-level approach
that really grabbed my attention so i
when i was an undergrad at ucla i read
one of his papers in a class and said
who is this guy because he said you have
to have a computational theory what is
being computed and why
an algorithm how is it being computed
what what are the percep
algorithms and then the hardware how
does it get instantiated in the hardware
and so to really do
he argued we needed to have
understanding of all those levels and i
that really got me i loved the
neuroscience but i realized this guy was
saying if you can't build it you don't
understand it effectively and so that's
why i went to mit and i had the pleasure
of working with david until he died as
just a year and a half later
so there was there's been that idea that
you know with neuroscience we we have to
have in some sense a top-down model of
what what
what's being computed and why that we
would then go after and same thing with
the you know trying to reverse engineer
you know a computing system like your
laptop
we really would we really need to
understand what the user interface is
about and why we have what are
keys on the
keyboard for and so forth you need to
know why
to really understand all the circuitry
and what it's what it's for
now
we don't the evolution of natural
selection
does not tell us the deeper question
that we're asking the answer to the
deeper question which is why what what
why
what what's this deeper reality and
what's it up to and why it all it tells
us is that whatever reality is
it's not what you see
what you see
is is just
an adaptive fiction
so just to linger on this fascinating
bold question
that shakes you out of
your dream state
does this fiction still help you in
building intuitions as literary fiction
does
about reality
the reason we read literary fiction
uh is it helps us
build intuitions and understanding in
indirect ways sneak up to the difficult
questions of human nature great fiction
same with this observed reality
um
does this interface that we get this
fictional interface help us build
intuition about deeper truths
of how this whole mess works
well
i think that
each theory that we propose will give
its own answer to that question right so
when the physicists are proposing um
these structures like the amplitude and
cosmological polytope sociohedron and so
forth beyond space time we can then ask
your question for those specific
structures and say how much information
for example
does evolution financial selection and
the the
kinds of sensory
systems that we have right now give us
about this deeper
reality and and
why did we evolve this way we can try to
answer that that question from within
the deeper so there's not going to be a
general answer i think we're going to
what we'll have to do is posit these new
deeper theories and then try to answer
your question
within the framework of those deeper
theories
knowing full well that there will be an
even deeper theory
so is it is this paralyzing though
because how do we know we're not
completely
adrift
uh out to sea
lost forever from
so like that our theories are completely
lost so if if if it's all
uh if we can never truly deeply
introspect to the bottom
if it's always just turtles on top of
turtles infinitely
um isn't that paralyzing for a
scientific mind
well
it's interesting that you say introspect
to the bottom
because there there is that there is one
i mean again this isn't the same spirit
of what i said before which is it
depends on what answer you give to
what's beyond space time what answer we
would give to your question right so but
one answer that um is interesting to
explore is something that spiritual
traditions have said for thousands of
years but haven't said precisely so
we can't take it seriously in science
until it's made precise but we might be
able to make it precise
and and that is that um
they've they've also said something like
um space and time aren't fundamental
they're maya they're their illusion
and but but that um
if you look inside if you introspect
and let go of all of your particular
perceptions
uh you will come to something that's
beyond conceptual thought
and that
is
they claim uh being in contact with the
deep ground of being that that
transcends any particular conceptual
understanding
if that is correct now i'm not saying is
correct
but and i'm not saying it's not correct
i'm just saying if that's correct
then it would be the case that as
scientists because
we also are in touch with this ground of
being
we would then
not be able to conceptually understand
ourselves all the way
but we could know ourselves just by
being ourselves
and so we would there would be a sense
in which
there is a fundamental grounding to the
whole
enterprise because we're not separate
from the enterprise
this is the opposite of third the
impersonal third person science this
this would make science be personal
personal all the way down
and and but but nevertheless scientific
because the scientific method would
still be
what we would use all the way
down for the conceptual understanding
unfortunately still don't know if you
went all the way down it's possible that
this kind of whatever consciousness is
and we'll talk about it is getting um
the cliche statement of be yourself
uh is is it is somehow digging at a
deeper truth of reality but you still
don't know when you get to the bottom
you know a lot of people they'll take
psychedelic drugs and they'll say well
that takes my mind to certain places
where it feels like that is revealing
some deeper truth of reality but it's
still
it could be interfaces on top of
interfaces that's that's um in your view
of this
you really don't know
it means gato's and completeness is that
you really don't know my own view on it
for what it's worth
because i don't know the right answer
but my own view on it right now is that
it um
it's never ending
i think that there will never that this
is great as i said before great um job
security for science
and that we
if this is true and if if consciousness
is somehow important or fundamental in
the universe this may be an important
fundamental fact about consciousness
itself that that it's the never-ending
exploration that's going on in some
sense
well well that's interesting you push
back on the job security okay
so maybe as we understand this kind of
idea deeper and deeper
we understand that the pursuit is not a
fruitful one
then maybe we need to
maybe that's why we don't see aliens
everywhere as you get smarter and
smarter and smarter you realize that
like exploration
is uh there's other fun ways to spend
your time than exploring
you could be
you could be sort of
living maximally in some way that's not
exploration
you know i could there's all kinds of
video games you can construct and put
yourself inside of them that don't
involve you going outside of the game
world
it's uh you know feeling
for my human perspective what seems to
be fun is challenging yourself and
overcoming those challenges so you can
constantly artificially generate
challenges for yourself like sisyphus
and his boulder
just
and and that's it so the scientific
method that's always reaching out to the
stars that's always trying to figure out
the puzzle on bottom puzzle the the
trick always trying to get to the bottom
turtle
maybe if we can
build more and more the intuition that
that's uh infinite pursuit
we get um
we agreed to start deviating from that
pursuit and start enjoying the here and
now versus the
looking out into the unknown always
maybe that's a looking out into the
unknown as a
early
activity
for a species
that's evolved i'm just sort of saying
uh pushing back because you probably got
a lot of scientists excited in terms of
job security i could i could envision
where it's not job security where
scientists become more and more useless
uh maybe they're like the holders of the
ancient wisdom
uh that's that allows us to study our
own history but
not much more than that just to get well
let's push back that's good push back
i'll i'll put one in there for the
scientists again yes but but sure but
then i'll take the other side too so
when
faraday did all of his experiments with
magnets and electricity and so forth he
came with all this wonderful empirical
data and
james clerk maxwell looked at it and
wrote down a few equations which we can
now write down in the single equation
the maxwell equation if we use geometric
algebra just one equation
that opened up
unbelievable technologies where you know
people are zooming and talking to each
other around the world
the whole electronics industry
there was something
that transformed our lives in a very
positive way
with the theories beyond space time
here's one potential
right now most of the galaxies that we
see
um we can see them but we know that we
could never get to them no matter how
fast we traveled they're going away from
us at
the speed of light or beyond so we can't
we can't ever get to them so there's all
this beautiful real estate that's just
smiling and waving at us and we can
never get to it
yeah but that's if we go through
spacetime
but if we recognize that spacetime is
just a data structure
it's not fundamental
we're not
little things inside space time
space-time is a little data structure
in our perceptions
it's just the other way around
once we understand that
and when we get equations for the stuff
that's beyond space time
maybe we won't have to go through space
time maybe we can go around it maybe i
can go to proxima centauri and not go
through space i can just
go right there directly it's a data
structure we can start to play with it
so so i think that
my for what it's worth my take would be
that
that the endless
sequence of theories that we could
contemplate building will lead to an
endless
sequence of new remarkable insights into
the potentialities the possibilities
that would that would that would seem
miraculous to us and that we will be
motivated to continue the exploration
partly
um just for the technological
innovations that that come out
but
you're the other thing that you
mentioned though what about just being
what if we when we decide instead of all
this doing and exploring what about
being my guess is that the best
scientists
will do both and that
the
act of being
will be a place where they get many of
their ideas
and that they then pull into the
conceptual realm and i think many of the
best scientists like einstein comes to
mind right where these guys say look i
didn't come up with these ideas by a
conceptual analysis
i was thinking in vague images and i was
it was just something
non-conceptual and then it took me a
long long time to pull it out into
concepts and then longer to put it into
math but the real insights didn't come
from just slavishly right you know
playing with equations they came from a
deeper place
and so there there may be this going
back and forth between the complete
non-conceptual
where there's essentially no end to the
wisdom and then conceptual systems where
there's the girdle limits um that we
have to that
and that may be if consciousness is
is important than fundamental that may
be what consciousness at least part of
what consciousness is about is this
discovering itself
discovering its possibilities so to
speak we can talk about what that might
mean
um
by
going from the non-conceptual to the
conceptual and back back and forth
to get better and better and better at
being
right
let me ask you just to linger on the
evolutionary
because you mentioned evolutionary game
theory and that's really where you
the perspective from which you come
to form the case against reality
uh
at which point in our evolutionary
history
do we start to deviate
the most from reality
is it
uh
is it way before life even originated on
earth
is it
um in the early development from
bacteria and so on
or is it when
some
inklings of what we think of as
intelligence or maybe even uh
complex consciousness
started to emerge so where did this
deviation
[Music]
just like with the interfaces on in a
computer you know you start with
transistors and then you have
assembly
and then you have
c c plus plus then you have python then
you have guise
and all that kind you have layers upon
layers when do we start to dva
well
david maher again my advisor at mit
in his book vision
suggested that the more primitive
sensory systems were less
realistic less vertical
but that by the time you got to
something as complicated as the humans
we were actually estimating the true
shapes and distances to objects and so
forth so so his point of view and i
think it was probably
it's
not an
uncommon view among
my colleagues that
that yeah the sensory systems of lower
creatures may just not be complicated
enough to give them much much truth
um but as you get you know to 86 billion
neurons you can now compute the truth or
at least the parts of the truth that we
need
when i look at evolutionary game theory
one of my graduate students justin mark
did some simulations using genetic
algorithms
so there he was just exploring
we start off with random organisms
random
sensory genetics and random
actions and the first generation was
unbelievably there were it was a
foraging situation they were foraging
for resources and most of them
you know stayed in one place didn't do
anything important and and
but
we could then just look at how the genes
evolved and and what we found was
what what what what he found was that uh
basically you never even saw
the the
truth
organisms even come on the stage they
they if they came but they were gone in
one generation they just they just
weren't
so they they they came and got they came
and went uh
even just in one generation they just
are not good enough the ones that were
just tracking their senses just were
tracking the fitness payoffs
were were far more um
fit than than um
the truth seekers
so from so an answer at one level i want
to give an answer at a deeper level but
just with evolutionary game theory
because my attitude as a scientist is um
i don't believe any of our theories
i take them very very seriously i study
them i look at their implications but
none of them are the gospel they're just
the latest ideas that we have and you
know so
the reason i study evolutionary game
theory is because that's the best tool
we have
right now in this area
there's there isn't nothing else that
competes and so as a scientist it's my
responsibility to take the best tools
and see what they mean and the same
thing the physicists are doing they're
taking the best tools and looking at
what what they entail
but i don't i i think that
science now has enough experience to
realize that we should not
believe our theories
in the sense that we've now arrived
in 1890 it was a lot of physicists
thought we'd arrived they were
discouraging um bright young
students from going into physics because
it was all done and that's precisely the
wrong attitude yeah forever this is the
wrong attitude forever
the attitude we should have is i uh a
century from now
they'll be looking at us and laughing at
what we didn't know and we just have to
assume that that's going to be the case
uh just just know that everything that
we think is so brilliant right now
our final theory a century from now
they'll look at us like we look at the
physicists of 1890 and go how could they
have been so dumb yeah so so i don't
want to make that mistake so so i'm not
doctrinaire about
any of our current scientific theories i
am dr nir about
this we should use the best tools we
have right now
with with humility well
so let me ask you about game theory
there's um i love game theory uh
evolution game theory
um but i'm always suspicious of it um
like economics
um when you construct models
it's too easy to construct things uh
that oversimplify
just
because we our human brains enjoy the
simplification
of constructing a few variables that
somehow represent organisms or represent
people
and running a simulation that then
allows you to build up intuition and it
feels really good because you guys can
get some really deep and surprising
intuitions but how do you know
your models aren't the assumptions
underlying your models on some
fundamentally flawed and because of that
your conclusions are fundamentally
flawed so i guess
my question is what are the limits in
your use of game theory evolution game
theory your experience with it what are
the limits of game theory
so i've gotten some pushback from
professional colleagues and friends
who have tried to rerun simulations and
try to i mean the idea that we don't see
the truth is not comfortable and so many
of my colleagues are very interested in
trying to show that we're wrong and so
the idea would be to say that somehow we
did something as you're suggesting maybe
something special that wasn't completely
general um we've got some little special
part of the whole search space and
evolutionary game theory in which this
happens to be true but more generally
organisms would evolve to see the truth
so the the best
pushback we've gotten is from a team at
yale
and uh they suggested that um if you use
thousands of payoff functions so we in
our simulations we just use a couple
one or two
because it was the first simulations
right so that would be a limit we had
one or two payoff functions we showed
the result in those
at least for the genetic algorithms and
they said if you have 20 000 of them
then we can find these conditions in
which um
truth seek seeing organisms would be the
ones that that evolved and survived
and so we looked at their simulations
and
and
it certainly is the case that you can
find special cases in which truth can
evolve so when i say it's probability
zero it doesn't mean it can't happen it
can happen in fact it could happen
infinitely often it's just probability
of zero so if probability of zero things
can happen infinitely often
when you say probability of zero you
mean probability close to zero
to be very precise so for example if i
have a unit square
on the plane
um and i use a measure in which the um
on a probability measure in which the
area of the region is this probability
then if i draw a curve
in that unit square
it has
measure precisely zero
precisely not approximately precisely
zero and yet it has infinitely many
points
so there's an object that for that
probability measure has probability of
zero and yet there's infinitely
infinitely many points in it so that's
what i what i mean when i say that the
things that are probability of zero can
happen infinitely often in principle
yeah but
infinity
as far as i and i look outside often i
walk around
and look at people i haven't never seen
infinity in real life
that's an interesting
issues i've been looking i've been
looking ahead i don't notice it
infinitely small or the infinitely big
and so the tools and mathematics you
could sort of apply the same kind of
criticism that it is a very convenient
interface
into our reality that's a big debate in
mathematics the intuitionists versus the
ones who take for example the real
numbers as as as as real and that's
that's a fun discussion nicholas giesen
has a physicist said really interesting
work recently on how if you go with
intuitionist mathematics
uh
you could effectively
quantize
newton and you find that the newtonian
theory and and quantum theory aren't
that different once you
go with it it's funny it's really quite
interesting so so the the issue you
raise is a very very deep one and one
that i think we should take quite
seriously
which is you know
how should we think about the reality of
the contours hierarchy aleph one lf2 and
all these
all these different
infinities
versus um
just
um
a more algorithmic approach right so
where it's everything's computable in
some sense everything's finite as big as
you want but but but nevertheless
finite
so yeah that ultimately boils down to
whether
the world
is discrete or continuous in some
general sense
and again we can't really know but
there's just a
mind-breaking
thought just common sense reasoning
that something can happen and this yet
probability of it happening is zero
percent
that doesn't that doesn't uh compute for
common sense computer
right um this is where you have to be a
sharp mathematician to really and i'm
not sharp is one word what i'm saying is
common sense computer is
i i mean that
[Music]
in a very kind of
in a positive sense
because we've been talking about
perception systems and interfaces
if we were if we are to reason about the
world we have to use the best interfaces
we got and i'm not exactly sure
uh that game theory
is the best interface we got for this oh
right and applications of mathematics
tricks and tools and mathematics the
game theory is the best we got when
we're thinking about the nature of
reality and fitness functions and
evolution period right well that's a
fair rejoinder and i think that um
that was the tool that we used and if if
someone says here's a better
mathematical tool and here's why this is
this mathematical tool better captures
the essence of darwin's idea
john maynard smith didn't quite get it
with evolutionary game theory there's
this better this thing now there are
tools like evolutionary graph theory
which generalize evolutionary game
theory and then there's quantum
game theory so so you can you can use uh
quantum tools like entanglement for
example as as a resource in games
that that change
the very nature of of the solutions of
the the optimal solutions of the game
theoretic well the the the work from
yale is really interesting it's a really
interesting challenge of that kind of
of these ideas where okay if you have a
very large number of fitness functions
or let's say you have
a nearly infinite number of fitness
functions or a growing number of fitness
functions what what kind of interesting
things uh start to emerging
emerging if you are to be an organism if
to be an organism that adapts means
having to deal with an ensemble of
fitness functions
right and so we've actually redone some
of our own
work based on those and this is the the
back and forth that we expect in science
right and what we found was that they
in their
simulations they were assuming that you
couldn't carve the world up into objects
that uh and so we said well let's relax
that assumption allow organisms to
create data structures that we might
call objects
and an object would be you take you you
would do hierarchical clustering of your
fitness payoff functions the ones that
have similar shapes if you have 20 000
of them maybe these 50 are all very very
similar so i can take all the perception
action fitness stuff and make that into
a data structure and we'll call that a
unit or an object
and as soon as we did that then all of
their results went away it turned out
they were the special case and that the
the organisms that were allowed to only
see that that were
shaped to see only fitness payoffs were
the ones that were
so so the idea is that objects then
what are objects from an evolutionary
point of view this bottle
we thought that when i saw a bottle it
was because i was seeing a true object
that existed whether or not it was
perceived
evolutionary
theories suggest a different
interpretation i'm seeing a data
structure that is encoding
a convenient way of looking at various
fitness payoffs i can use this for
drinking
i could use it as a weapon not very good
one i could beat someone with head with
it um if my goal is mating this is
pointless
so i'm seeing for what i'm coding here
is all sorts of
actions and the payoffs that i could get
when i pick up an apple now i'm getting
a different set of actions and pay and
payoffs for when i pick up a rock i'm
getting so for every object what i'm
getting is a different set of payoff
functions
um and act
with various actions and so once you
allow that
then what you find is once once again
that
truth goes extinct and the organisms
that just get an interface are the ones
that that win
but the question uh just sneaking up on
this is fascinating
from where do fitness functions
originate
what gives birth to the fitness
functions so
if there's a giant black box that just
keeps giving you fitness functions what
are we trying to optimize you said that
water
uh
has different
um
uses
than an apple so there's these objects
what are we trying to optimize and why
is not
reality a really good generator of
fitness functions
so each theory makes its own assumptions
and says grant me this then i'll explain
that so evolutionary game theory says
grant me fitness payoffs
right and grant me strategies with
payoffs and
i can write down the matrix for this
strategy interacts with that strategy
these are the payoffs that come up if
you grant me that then i can start to to
explain a lot of things now you can ask
for a deeper question like okay
how does physics
evolve
biology and where do these fitness
payoffs
come from right now
that would be that's a completely
different enterprise and of course
evolutionary game theory then would be
not the right tool for that it would
have to be a deeper tool that shows
where evolutionary game theory comes
from
my own take is
that
there's going to be a problem in doing
that
because
space time isn't fundamental
it's just a user interface
and that the distinction that we make
between living and non-living
is not a fundamental distinction
it's an artifact of the limits of our
interface
right so this is a new wrinkle and this
is an important wrinkle what
it's so nice to take space and time is
fundamental because if something looks
like it's inanimate it's inanimate and
we can just say it's it's not living
now
it's much more complicated
certain things are obviously living i'm
talking with you
there's i'm obviously interacting with
some something that's alive and
conscious
i think we've let go of the word
obviously in this conversation i think
nothing is obvious this is obvious
that's right
but when we get down to you to like you
know
an ant it's obviously living but i'll
say it it appears to be living it won't
get down to a virus now people wonder
and when we get down to you know protons
people say it's not living and and my
attitude is look i have a user interface
the interface is there to hide certain
aspects of reality and others to to
to
it's an uneven representation put it
that way certain things just get
completely hidden
dark matter and dark energy are most of
the energy and matter that's out there
our interface just plain flat out hides
them
the only way we get some hint is because
gravitational things are going wrong
within our
so so most things are outside of our of
our interface the distinction between
living and non-living
is not fundamental it's an artifact of
our interface so if so this is the if we
really
really want to understand where
evolution comes from
to answer the question the deep question
you asked i think the the right way
we're going to do that is to come up
with a deeper theory than space time
in which there may not be the notion of
time
and
show that
whatever this dynamics of that deeper
theory is
and by the way i'll talk about how you
could have dynamics without time but the
the dynamics of this deeper theory when
we project it into
in certain ways then we do get space
time and we get what appears to be
evolution by natural selection so i
would love to see evolution by natural
selection nature red and tooth and claw
people fighting and animals fighting for
resources and a whole bit come out of a
deeper theory which perhaps it's all
cooperation there's no no limited
resources and so forth but as a result
of projection
you get space and time and as a result
of projection you get nature red and
tooth and claw the appearance of it but
it's all an artifact of the interface i
like this idea
that uh the line between living and
non-living is very important
because that's that's the thing that
would emerge before you have evolution
the idea of death
so
that seems to be an important component
of natural selection if and if that
emerged because that's also
um
you know asking the question i guess
that i asked where do fitness come
fitness functions come from that's like
asking
the the old meaning of life question
right it's a what's the why why
why
and
one of the big underlying lies okay you
can start with evolution on earth but
without living
without life and death without the line
between the living and the dead
you don't have evolution
so what if underneath it there's no such
thing as the living and the dead
there's no
like this concept of an organism period
there's a living organism that's defined
by a volume in space-time
that somehow interacts
that over time maintains its integrity
somehow
it has some kind of history it has a
wall of some kind the outside world the
environment and then inside there's an
organism
so you're defining an organism and also
you're defining that organism by the
fact that it can move
and it can be come alive which you kind
of think of as moving
combined with the fact that it's keeping
itself separate from the environment so
you can point out that thing is living
and then it can also die
that seems to be of all very
powerful components of space time that
enable you to have something like
natural selection and evolution
well and there's a lot of interesting
work some of it um by collaborators of
carl fristen and others where they
they have um
bayes net kind of stuff that they built
on in the notion of a markov blanket so
you have some states
within this network that are inside the
blanket then you have the blanket and
then the state's outside the blanket and
the states inside this markov blanket
are conditionally independent of the
states outside the blank blanket
conditioned on the blanket and what
they're what they're looking at is that
the dynamics inside of the states inside
the markel blanket seem to be trying to
estimate properties of the outside and
and react to them in a way so it seems
like you're doing probabilistic
inferences in ways that might be able to
to keep your life so there's interesting
work going on in in that direction but
but but
what i'm saying is is something slightly
different and that is
like when i when i look at you
all i see is skin hair and eyes right
that's all i see
but
i know that there's a deeper reality i
believe that there's a much deeper
reality there's the whole world of your
experiences your thoughts your hopes
your dreams
in some sense the face that i see
is is just a symbol that i create right
and as soon as i look away that i delete
that symbol but i don't delete you i
don't delete the conscious experience
the the whole world of your so i i'm
only deleting an interface symbol but
that interface symbol
is a
portal so to speak
not a
perfect portal but
a genuine portal into your beliefs into
your conscious experiences into
that's why we can have a conversation we
genuinely but your consciousness is
genuinely affecting mine and mine is
genuinely affecting yours through these
icons which which i create on the fly i
mean i create your face when i look i
delete it i don't create you your
consciousness that's there all the time
um but but i do so
now when i look at a cat i'm creating
something that i still call living and i
still think it's conscious when i look
at an ant
i create something that i still would
call living but maybe not conscious when
i look at something i call a virus now
i'm not even sure i would call it living
and when i look at a proton i would say
i don't even think it's not alive at all
it could be
that i'm nevertheless
interacting with something that's just
as conscious as you i'm not saying the
proton is conscious the face that i'm
creating when i look at you that face is
not conscious that face is a data
structure
in me that face isn't it
it's an experience it's not an
experiencer
similarly a proton is is is something
that i create you know when i look or do
a collision in the large hadron collider
or something like that
but
what is behind the entity in space time
so i've got this space-time interface
and i've just got this entity that i
call a proton what is the reality behind
it well the physicists are finding these
big big structures
the sociohedron
what's behind those
could be consciousness
what i'm playing with in which case when
i'm interacting with a proton
i could be interacting with
consciousness again to be very very
clear because easily
i'm not saying a proton is conscious
just like i'm not saying your face is
conscious your face is a symbol i create
and then delete
as i look and so your face is not
conscious but i know that that face in
my interface the lex friedman face that
i create is an interface symbol that's a
genuine portal into your consciousness
the portal is
less clear for a cat even less clear for
an ant and by the time we get down to a
proton the portal is not clear at all
but that doesn't mean i'm not
interacting with consciousness it just
means my interface gave up
and there's some some deeper reality
that we have to go after so so that so
your question really forces out a big
part of this whole approach that i'm
talking about
so it's this portal unconscious i wonder
why
you can't
your portal is not as good to a cat
to the cast consciousness
than it is to a human does it have to be
have to do with the fact that you're
human
and just similar organisms organisms
that similar complexity are able to
create portals
better to each other or is it just as
you get more and more complex you get
better and better portals
well let me answer one one aspect that
i'm more confident about then i'll
speculate on that
why is why is it that the portal is so
bad with protons
well and and and elementary particles
more generally so quarks leptons and
gluons and so forth
well the reason for that is because
those are just
symmetries of space-time
more technically they're irreducible
representations of the poincare group of
space-time
so they're just
literally representations
of the data structure of space-time that
we're using
so that's why they're not very much
insightful they're they're just almost
entirely tied to the data structure
itself there's there's not much
that they're telling you only something
about the data structure not behind the
data structure it's only when we get to
higher levels that we're starting to in
some sense build portals to what's
behind
space time sure yeah so there's more and
more
um
complexity built on top of the
interface of space time with the cat so
you can actually build a portal right
yeah
yeah right
yeah i this interface of face and hair
and so on
my skin
there is some sinking going on between
humans though where we think like
you're you're getting a pretty good
representation of the ideas in my head
and starting to get a
foggy view
of uh my memories in my head even though
you know this is the first time we're
talking you start to project your own
memories you start to solve like
a giant hierarchy of puzzles about a
human
because we're all uh there's a lot of
similarities a lot of it rhymes so you
start to make a lot of inferences you
build up this model
of a person you have a pretty
sophisticated model what's going on
underneath
again i just
i wonder if it's possible to construct
these models about each other and
nevertheless be very distant from an
underlying reality
there's a lot of work on this so there's
some interesting work called signaling
games where they they look at how people
can coordinate and
come to communicate
there's some interesting work that was
done by some colleagues and friends of
mine
louis nerens natalia komarova and
kimberly jamison where they
we're looking at
evolving
color words so you have a a circle of
colors you know this is the color circle
and they
wanted to see if they could get people
to cooperate and how they carved the
color circle up into two units of words
and
so they had a game
theoretic kind of thing that they'd had
people do and what they found was that
when they included so
most people are trichromats you have
three kinds of cone photoreceptors but
there are some a lot of men seven
percent of men have are dichromates they
might be missing the red cone
photoreceptor
they found that the dichromats
had an outsized influence
on the final ways that the whole space
of colors was carved up and and labels
attached you needed to be able to
include the dichromats in the
conversation and so they had a bigger
influence on how you made the boundaries
of the language i thought that was a
really interesting kind of insight that
there's going to be again a game perhaps
a game where evolutionary or genetic
algorithm kind of thing that goes on in
terms of
learning to communicate in ways that
that are useful
and
so yeah you can use game theory to to
actually explore that or signaling games
um there's a lot of brilliant work on
that i'm not doing it but there's work
out there
so if it's okay let us tackle once more
and perhaps several more times after
the big topic of consciousness okay
this this very beautiful powerful things
that perhaps is the thing that makes us
human what is it what's the role of
consciousness in um
let's say even just the thing we've been
talking about which is the formation of
this interface
um
but any kind of ways you want to kind of
start sure uh tracking and talking about
it
well let me say first what most of my
colleagues say
99
are again assuming that space time is
fundamental
particles in space-time matter is
fundamental
and most are reductionist
and so the standard approach to
consciousness is to figure out
what
complicated systems of matter
with the right functional properties
could possibly lead to the emergence of
consciousness that's the general idea
right
so
maybe you have to have neurons maybe
only if you have neurons but
that might not be enough they have to
certain kinds of complexity in their
their organization and their dynamics
certain kind of network abilities for
example
so there's
there are those who say for example that
consciousness arises from orchestrated
collapse of quantum states of
microtubules in neurons certain
so this is
hamroff and penrose have that's kind of
so it's it's a you start with something
physical
a
property of quantum states of neurons
of microtubules and neurons and you say
that somehow an orchestrated collapse of
those
is consciousness or conscious
experiences
or integrated information theory again
you start with something physical
and if it has the right kind of
functional properties that's something
they call fee with the right kind of
integrated information then you have
consciousness
or you can be a pan psychist
philip gough for example where you you
might say well in addition to the
particles in space and time
those particles are not just matter they
also could have say a unit of
consciousness
and so but once again you're taking
space and time and particles as
fundamental
and you're adding
a new property to them see their
consciousness and then you have to talk
about how when a proton and neutron
where proton and electron get together
to form hydrogen then how those
consciousnesses
merge to or interact to create the
clutchness of hydrogen and so forth
um there's a tension schema theory which
again this is how neural network
processes representing to the network
itself its attentional processes that
could be consciousness um there's global
workspace theory
and neuronal global work experience
workspace theory so there's many many
theories of this type what's what's
common to all of them
is they assume that spacetime is
fundamental
they assume that physical processes and
space time is fundamental
pan psychism adds consciousness says an
additional thing is almost duelist in
that regard
and
my attitude is
our best science is telling us
that space-time is not fundamental
so
why is that important here
well for centuries
deep thinkers
thought of
earth air fire and water as the
fundamental elements it was a
reductionist kind of idea
nothing was more elemental than those
and you could you could sort of build
everything up from those
when we got the periodic table of
elements
we realized that um
of course we want to study earth air
fire and water there's combustion
science for fire there's you know
um there's sciences for for
all these other things water and so
forth so we're going to do science with
these things but but fundamental no no
if you're looking for something
fundamental those are the wrong building
blocks
earth has many many different kinds of
elements
that project into the one thing that we
call earth if you don't understand that
there's silicon that there's iron that
there's all these different kinds of
things that project into what we call
earth
you're
you're you're hopelessly lost you're not
fundamental you're not going to get
there and then
after the periodic table then we came up
with quarks leptons and gluons the the
particles of the standard you know the
standard model of physics
and and and so we actually now know that
if you really want to get fundamental
the periodic table isn't it it's good
for chemistry it's just wonderful for
chemistry but if you're trying to go
deep fundamental what is the fundamental
science that's not it you're going to
have to go to
quarks leptons and gluons and so forth
well now
we've discovered space-time itself is
doomed quarks leptons and gluons are
just irreducible representations of the
symmetries of space-time
so the whole framework on which
consciousness research is being based
right now
is doomed
and for me
these are my friends and colleagues
that are doing this they're brilliant
they're absolutely they're they're
brilliant i
my feeling is i i'm so sad
that they're stuck with this old
framework because if they they weren't
stuck like with earth air fire and water
you could actually make progress so it
doesn't matter how smart you are if you
start with earth air fire and water
you're not going to get anywhere right
can i actually just uh uh because the
word doomed is so interesting
let me give you some options multiple
choice quiz
is space time we could say is reality
the way we perceive it
doomed
um
wrong
or
fake
because doomed just means it could still
be right
and we're now ready to go deeper
it would be that so it's not wrong it's
not a complete
deviation from a journey toward the
truth
right it's like earth air fire and water
is not wrong there is earth air fire and
water that's a useful framework but it's
not fundamental
right well there's also wrong which is
they used to believe as i recently
learned that george washington was the
president of the first president in the
united states was bled to death
uh for something that could have been
easily treated
uh because it was believed that you can
get actually i need to look into this
further but i guess you get toxins out
or demons out i don't know what you're
getting out with the bleeding of a
person right
but so that end up being wrong but
widely believed as a medical
tool
so
it's also possible that
our assumption of space-time is not just
doomed but it's wrong
well if we believe that it's fundamental
that's wrong
but if we believe it's a useful tool
that's right but he could see but
bleeding somebody to death was believed
to be a useful tool and that was true
it wasn't just not fundamental right it
was
very
i'm sure there's cases in which bleeding
somebody would work but it would be a
very tiny tiny tiny percentage of cases
so it could be that it's wrong like it's
a side road that's ultimately leading to
a dead end
as opposed to a truck stop or something
that you can get off of
my feeling is not the dead end kind of
thing i i think that the what the
physicists are finding is that there are
these structures beyond space time but
they project back into space time and so
space time
when they when they say space time is
doomed they're explicit they're saying
it's doomed in the sense that we thought
it was fundamental it's not fundamental
right it's a useful absolutely useful
and brilliant data structure but there
are deeper data structures like
cosmological polytube
and and and space-time is not
fundamental what is doomed
in the sense that it's wrong
is
reductionism
which is saying space-time is
fundamental
right right the idea that that somehow
being smaller in space and time or space
time is a fundamental nature of reality
that's is a that's that's just wrong it
turned out to be a useful heuristic for
for thermodynamics and so forth and
several other places it reductionism has
been very useful but that's in some
sense
an artifact of how we use our interface
um
yeah so you're saying size doesn't
matter okay this is very important for
me
ultimately ultimately right i mean it's
useful
for for theories like thermodynamics and
also for understanding brain networks in
terms of of
individual neurons and neurons in terms
of
chemical
systems inside cells that's all very
very useful but but the idea that we're
getting to the more fundamental nature
of reality
no when you when you get all the way
down in that direction you get down to
the quarks and gluons what you realize
is what you've gotten down to is not
fundamental reality just the irreducible
representations of a data structure
that's all you've gotten down to so
you're always stuck
inside the data structure
so you seem to be getting closer and
closer i went from neural networks to
neurons neurons to chemistry chemistry
to particles particles to clerks and
gluons
i'm getting closer and closer to the
ground no i'm getting closer and closer
to the the actual structure of the data
structure of space and time the
irreducible representation so that's
what you're getting closer to not to a
deeper understanding of what's beyond
space-time we'll also refer
we'll return again to this question of
dynamics
because you keep
saying that space-time is doomed but
mostly focusing on the space part of
that it's very interesting to see why
why time gets the bad cred too because
how do you have dynamics without time is
the thing i'd love to talk to you a
little bit about but let us return
um
your brilliant
whirlwind overview of the different
theories of consciousness that are out
there
what is consciousness if
outside of space-time
if we think that we want to have a model
of consciousness we as scientists then
have to
say what do we want to write down what
what what kind of mathematical model are
we going to write down right and if you
think about it there's lots of things
that you might want to write down about
consciousness
really complicated subject
so most of my colleagues are saying
let's start with matter or neurons and
and
say what properties of matter could
create consciousness but i'm saying that
that whole thing is out
space time is doomed that whole thing is
out
we need to look at consciousness qua
consciousness
in other words not as something that
arises in space and time but perhaps
it's something that creates space and
time as a data structure
so what do we want and here again
there's no hard and fast rule but what
you as a scientist have to do is to pick
what you think are the minimal
assumptions
that are going to allow you to boot up
a comprehensive theory
that is the trick
so what do i want so what what i chose
to do was to have three things
i said that there are conscious
experiences
feeling of headache the smell of garlic
um
experiencing the color red there are
those are conscious so that's a
primitive theory and the reason i want
few primitives why because those are the
miracles of the theory right the
primitives the assumptions of your
theory are the things you're not going
to explain those are the things you
assume and those experiences you
particularly mean
there's a subjectiveness to them that's
what's the thing when people refer to
the heart problem of consciousness
is it feels like something
to look at the color red okay exactly
right it feels like something to have a
headache or to feel
upset to your stomach it feels like
something
and so though so i'm going to grant that
in this theory
there are experiences and they're
fundamental in some sense so conscious
experience so they're not derived from
physics they're not
functional properties of particles they
are sewed generous they're they exist
just like we assume space-time exists
i'm now saying space-time is just a data
structure it doesn't exist independent
of
conscious experiences sorry to interrupt
once again but should we be focusing in
your thinking on humans alone
or is there something
about
in relation to other kinds of organisms
that have a sufficiently high level of
complexity or even
or is there some kind of
uh
generalization of the pan cyclist idea
that all
consciousness permeates all matter
outside of the usual definition of what
matter is inside space-time so
it's beyond human consciousness human
consciousness from my point of view
would be
one of a countless variety of
consciousnesses
and even within human consciousness
there's a there's countless variety of
consciousness within us right
you have your left and right hemisphere
and apparently if you split the corpus
callosum the the personality of the left
hemisphere and the religious beliefs of
the left hemisphere can be very
different from the right hemisphere and
their conscious experiences
can be
disjoint one could have one conscious
experience they can play 20 questions
the left hemisphere can have an idea in
its mind and the right hemisphere has to
guess and it might not get it so so even
within you there is more than just one
consciousness it's
lots of consciousnesses so i the the
general theory of consciousness that i'm
after is not just human consciousness
it's going to be just consciousness and
i presume human consciousness is a tiny
drop in the bucket of the infinite
variety of consciousnesses that said i
should clarify that the black hole of
consciousness is uh
the the home cat i'm pretty sure cats
lack
uh is the embodiment of evil and lack
all capacity for consciousness or uh
compassion so i just want to lay that on
there but that's the theory i'm working
i i don't have any good evidence
that's just a shout out
sorry to distract so that's the first
assumption first assumption that's right
the second assumption is that these
experiences have consequences
so
i'm going to say that conscious
experiences can trigger other conscious
experiences somehow
so
so really in some sense there there's
two basic assumptions there's some kind
of causality is there's a chain of
causality does this relate to dynamics
i'll say there's a probabilistic
relationship okay
um and then
so i'm trying to be
as non-specific to begin with and see
where it leads me so what i can write
down are probability spaces so
probability space which contains the
conscious experiences that this
consciousness can have so i i'll
i call this a conscious agent
this technical thing now i
annika harris and i've talked about this
and and she rightly
cautions me that people will think that
i'm bringing in a notion of a cell for
agency and so forth when i say conscious
agent so i just want to say that i use
the term conscious agent merely as a
technical term there is no notion of
self in my fundamental definition of a
conscious age there are only experiences
and probabilistic relationships that of
how they trigger other experiences so
the agent is the generator of the
conscious experience the agent
is a mathematical structure that
includes a probability measure
a probability space
of possible conscious experiences and
what in a markovian kernel
which describes how if this agent has
certain conscious experiences how that
will affect the experiences of other
conscious agents
okay including itself but you don't
think of that as a self no there there
is no notion of of a self here there's
no notion of of really of an agent
but is there a locality
is there an organization
so this is this is um these are
conscious
units conscious entities but they're
distinct
in some way because they have to
interact
well so here's the interesting thing
when we write down the mathematics um
when you have two of these conscious
agents interacting they s the the pair
satisfy the definition of a conscious
agent so they are a single conscious
agent
so there is one conscious agent yeah but
it it has a nice analytic decomposition
into as many conscious agents that's a
nice interface
it's a very useful scientific interface
yeah it's it's a scale-free or if you
like a fractal-like
approach to it in which we can use the
same unit of analysis at all scales in
in studying consciousness but if i want
to talk about
so there's no notion of learning
memory
problem solving intelligence self
agency
so none of that is fundamental
so and the reason i did that was
because
i want to assume as little as possible
everything i assume is a miracle in the
theory it's not something you explain is
something you assume so i have to build
networks of conscious agents
if i want to have a notion of a self i
have to build a self
i have to build learning memory problem
solving intelligence and planning all
these different things i have to build
networks of conscious agents to do that
it's a trivial theorem that networks of
conscious agents are computationally
universal that's trivial so anything
that we can do with neural networks or
you know
automata you can do with networks of
conscious agents that's trivial
but
but you can also do more
the
events in the probability space need not
be computable so the markovian dynamics
is not restricted to computable
functions
because the very events themselves need
not be computable
so so this can capture any computable
theory
anything we can do with neural networks
we can do with conscious agent networks
but but it leaves open the door for the
possibility of non-computable
interactions between conscious agents so
we have to to if we want a theory of of
memory
we have to build it and there's lots of
different ways you could build we've
actually got a paper chris fields took
the lead on this and he
we have a paper called conscious agent
networks where where chris takes the
lead and shows how to use these networks
of conscious agents to build memory and
to build
primitive kinds of of learning
but
can you provide some intuition of what
conscious networks
network of conscious networks of
conscious agents
helps you
well first of all what that looks like
and i don't just mean mathematically of
course maybe that might help build up
intuition but how that helps us
potentially solve the heart problem of
consciousness
right
or is that
baked in that that exists
is the
can you solve the hard problem of
consciousness
why it tastes delicious when you eat a
delicious ice cream
with networks of conscious agents or is
that taken as an assumption so the the
standard way the heart problem
is thought of is
we're
assuming space and time and particles or
neurons for example
these are just physical things that that
have no consciousness and we have to
explain how the conscious experience of
the taste of chocolate could emerge from
those so that's the typical hard problem
of consciousness is that problem right
how do you boot up the taste of
chocolate the experience of the taste of
chocolate from
neurons say or the right kind of
artificial intelligence circuitry
how do you boot that up that's that's
typically what the hard problem of
consciousness means to to researchers
notice that i'm changing the problem
i'm not trying to boot up conscious
experiences from the dynamics of neurons
or silicon or something like that i'm
saying that that's the wrong problem
my heart problem would go in the other
direction if i start with conscious
experiences
how do i build up space and time how do
i build up what i call the physical
world how do i build up what we call
brains
because i'm saying
consciousness is not something that
brains do
brains are something that consciousness
makes up
it's one among the experience it's an
experience an ephemeral experience in
consciousness
i look inside so i'll to be very very
clear right now i have no neurons
if you looked
you would see neurons that's a data
structure that you would create on the
fly and it's a very useful one as soon
as you look away you garbage collect
that data structure just like that necro
cube that i was talking about on the
piece of paper when you look you see a
3d cube
you create it on the fly as soon as you
look away
that's gone when you say you you mean a
human being scientist
right now that's right
more generally it'll be conscious agents
because as you as you pointed out in my
asking
for a theory of conscience only about
humans no it's it's
consciousness which human consciousness
is just a tiny
sliver
so but you are saying that there is
that's a useful data structure how many
other data structures are there that's
why i said you human if there's another
earth
if there's another alien civilization
and doing these kinds of investigations
would they come up with similar data
structures
probably not what is the space of data
structures i guess is what i'm asking um
my my guess is that
if consciousness is
fundamental consciousness is all there
is
then
the only thing
that mathematical structure can be about
is possibilities of consciousness
and
that suggests to me that there could be
an infinite variety of consciousnesses
and
a
vanishingly small fraction of them use
space-time
data structures and the kinds of
structures that we use
there's an infinite variety of data
structures now this is very similar to
something that max tegmark has said but
i want to distinguish it he has this his
level 4
multiverse idea he thinks that
mathematics is fundamental
and and so that's the fundamental
reality and since there's an infinite
variety of
endless variety of mathematical
structures there's an infinite variety
of multiverses in his view
i'm saying something
similar in spirit but importantly
different there's an infinite variety of
mathematical structures absolutely
but mathematics isn't the fundamental
reality in this in this framework
consciousness is
and mathematics is to consciousness
like bones are to an organism
you need the bones so mathematics is is
not divorced from consciousness but it's
not
the entirety of consciousness by any
means
and so there's an infinite variety of of
conscious consciousnesses and and
signaling games that consciousnesses
could interact
via
and therefore worlds you know common
worlds data structures
that they can use to to communicate
so space and time is just one of an
infinite variety and so i i think that
what we'll what we'll find is that as we
go outside of our little space-time
bubble
um
we will encounter
utterly alien forms of conscious
experience that we may not be able to
really
comprehend in the in the following sense
if i if i ask you to imagine a color
that you've never seen before
does anything happen
right nothing happens
nothing happens and and
that's just one color i'm asking for
just a color we we actually know by the
way that there apparently there are
women
um called tetraphams
um who have four color receptors
not just three
and kimberly jamison and others who
studied these women have good evidence
that they apparently have a new
dimension of color experience
that the rest of us don't have so so
these women are apparently living in a
world of color that you and i can't even
concretely imagine no man can imagine
them yeah and and yet they're real color
experiences and so in that sense i'm
saying now take that little baby step oh
there are women who have color
experiences that i could never have well
that's shocking
now take that
infinite
there are consciousnesses
where every aspect of their
their experiences or is like that new
color it's something utterly alien to
you you you'd have nothing like that and
yet these are all possible varieties of
conscious experience when you say
there's a lot of consciousnesses it's a
singular consciousness
basically the set of possible
experiences you can have in a subjective
way
as opposed to the met the underlying
mechanism
because you say that you know having uh
extra color receptor
uh ex
ability to have new experiences that's
somehow a different consciousness is
there a way to see that as all the same
consciousness the subjectivity itself
right because when we have
two of these conscious agents
interacting in the mathematics they
actually satisfy the definition of a
conscious agent so in fact they are a
single conscious agent
so so in fact
one way to think about what i'm saying
i'm postulating with my colleagues
jayton and chris and others robert
prentner and so forth
there is one big conscious agent
infinitely complicated
but fortunately
we can for analytic purposes break it
down all the way to in some sense the
simplest conscious agent which has one
conscious experience one
i like this this one agent can
experience red 35 that's it that's what
that's what it experiences you can get
all the way down to that
so you think it's possible
that consciousness
whatever that
is is uh
much more is fundamental or at least
much more in the direction of the
fundamental
than his space time as we perceive it
that's the proposal
and therefore what i have to do in terms
of the heart problem of consciousness
is to show
how dynamical systems of conscious
agents could lead to what we call space
and time and neurons
and brain activity
in other words we have to show
how you get space-time and
physical objects
in entirely from a theory of conscious
agents outside of space time with the
dynamics outside of space-time
so that's that's and i can tell you how
we plan to to do that but but that's
that's the idea
okay the magic of it that chocolate is
delicious
so so there's a mathematical kind of
thing that we could say here how it can
emerge within the system of networks of
conscience agents but
um
is there going to be at the end of of
the proof why chocolate is so delicious
or or no i guess i'm going to ask
different kinds of dumb questions to try
to sneak up oh well that's the right
question and when i say that i took
conscious experiences as fundamental
what that means is in the current
version of my theory i'm not explaining
conscious experiences where they came
from
that's the miracle that's one of the
miracles so i have two miracles in my
theory there are conscious experiences
like the taste of chocolate
and
that the
there's a probabilistic relationship
when certain conscious experiences occur
others are more likely to occur
those are the two miracles that
are possible to
get beyond
that
and somehow start to chip away at the
miracleness of that miracle that
chocolate is still delicious i hope so
i've got my hands full with what i'm
doing right now but but the
i can just say at top level how i would
think about that that would get at this
consciousness without form
this is going to be really this is
really tough because it's
consciousness without form versus the
various forms that consciousness
takes for the experiences that it has
right right
so there's
so when i write down
a probability space
for these conscious experience i say
here's a probability space for the
possible conscious experiences
right
it's just like when i write down a
probability space for an experiment like
i'm going to flip
a coin twice
right and i want to look at the
probabilities of various outcomes so i
have to write down the probability space
there could be heads heads heads tails
tails heads tails tails
so you before as
any class and probability you're told
write down your probability space if you
don't write down your probability space
you can't get started
so here's my probability space for
consciousness how do i want to interpret
that structure
the structure is just sitting there
there's going to be a dynamics that
happens on it right experiences appear
and then it disappear just like heads
appears and disappears
so
so
one way to think about that fundamental
probability space is that
corresponds to consciousness without any
content
the infinite consciousness
that transcends
any particular content
well do you think of that as a mechanism
as a thing
like the the rules that govern the
dynamics of the thing
outside of space time isn't that if you
think consciousness is fundamental isn't
it essentially getting like
it is solving the hard problem
which is like
from uh
where does this thing pop up
which is the mechanism of the thing
popping up
whatever the consciousness is the
different kinds it was so on that
mechanism
and also the the question i want to ask
is uh
how
how tricky do you think it is
to solve that problem
you solved a lot of difficult problems
throughout the history of humanity
there's probably
more problems to solve
left than we've solved
by like
an infinity
uh but along that long journey
of intelligent species
how when when we solve this
consciousness one which is one way to
measure the difficulty of the problem
so i'll give two answers there's one
problem i think we can solve
but we haven't solved yet and that is
the reverse of what
my colleagues call the heart problem
the problem of how do you start with
conscious experiences in the way that
i've just described them in the dynamics
and build up space and time and brains
that i think is a tough technical
problem but some principle solvable so i
think we can solve that so we would
solve the hard problem not by showing
how brains create consciousness but how
networks of conscious agents create what
we call the the symbols that we call
brains
so that that i think but that does that
allow you to so that's interesting
that's an interesting idea consciousness
creates the brain not the brain creates
consciousness but does that allow you to
build the thing
my guess is that it will
enable unbelievable technologies once
and i'll tell you why i think it plugs
into the work that the physicists are
doing so this theory of consciousness
will be even deeper than the structures
that the physicists are finding like the
amplitude
but the other but the other answer to
your question is less positive
i as i said earlier i think that there
is no such thing as a theory of
everything
so that
i think that my
the theory that my team is working on
this conscious station theory is just a
1.0 theory theory
we're using
probability spaces and markovian curls i
can easily see people now saying well we
can do better if we go to category
theory
and we can
get a deeper perhaps more interesting
and then someone will say well now i'll
go to topoi theory and then they'll be
so i imagine that there'll be you know
conscious agents five
ten
3 trillion 0.0
but i think it will never end i think
ultimately
this question that we sort of put our
fingers on of
how
does the formless
give birth to form
to the taste the wonderful taste of
chocolate
i think that we will always go
deeper and deeper but we will never
solve that
that that in some sense that will be a
primitive i hope i'm wrong
maybe i'm maybe it's just the the limits
of my current imagination
um
so i'll just say my imagination right
now
doesn't
appear that deep
hopefully so i don't by the way i'm
saying this i don't want to discourage
some brilliant 20 year old
who then later on proves me dead wrong i
hope to be proven dead right just like
you said essentially from now everything
we're saying now everything you're
saying all your theories will be
laughing stock they will respect the uh
the the the puzzle solving abilities and
how how much we were able to do with so
little but uh outside of that
it will all be just uh the silliness
will be entertainment for a teenager
especially the silliness when we thought
that we were so smart and we knew it all
so it would be interesting to explore
your ideas by contrasting
you mentioned annika monica harris you
mentioned um phil goff
so outside of if you're not allowed to
say
the fundamental disagreement is the fact
that space time is fundamental
um what are interesting
distinctions between ideas of
consciousness between you and hanukkah
for example you guys have uh you've been
on a podcast together i'm sure
in in in in private you guys have some
incredible conversations so what where
are some sticky interesting sticking
points some
interesting disagreements let's say with
annika first maybe there'll be a few
other people well annika and i just had
a conversation this morning where we
were talking about our ideas and what we
discovered really in our conversation
was that um
we're pretty much on the same page it
was really just
consciousness unconsciousness yeah we're
our ideas about consciousness are pretty
much on the same page
she
rightly has cautioned me to when i talk
about conscious agents
to point out that the notion of agency
is not for is not fundamental in my my
theory
the notion of self is not fundamental
that's that's absolutely true i can use
this network of conscious agents this
and i now use tech
as a technical term conscious agent is a
technical term for that probability
space with the markovian dynamics
i can use that to build models of a self
and to build models of agency but
they're not they're not fundamental so
she she has
really um more been very helpful in in
helping me to be a little bit clear
about these ideas and not say things
that are misleading
sure the word i mean this is the
interesting thing about language
actually is that language quite
obviously is an interface
yes um to truth
it's it's so fascinating that
individual words
can have so
much ambiguity
and the the and the slight the
specific choices of a word within a
particular sentence within the context
of a sentence can have so much uh such a
difference in meaning it's quite
fascinating
especially when you're talking about
topics like consciousness
because it's a very loaded term it means
a lot of things to a lot of people
and the entire concept is shrouded or
mystery so combination of the fact that
it's a loaded term and that there's a
lot of mystery
people can just interpret it in all
kinds of ways and so you have to be both
precise and help them avoid getting um
stuck
on some kind of side road of
miscommunication
lost in translation because you used the
wrong word that's interesting i mean
because for for a lot of people
consciousness is
ultimately
connected to a self
i mean
that's our our experience of
consciousness is very
it's connected to this ego i mean i just
i mean what else could it possibly be i
can't even how do you begin to
comprehend to visualize
to conceptualize a consciousness that's
not connected to like this particular
organism
well i have a way of thinking about this
whole problem now that's that's that
comes out of this this framework that's
different
so
we can imagine a dynamics of
consciousness
not in space and time just
abstractly
it could be cooperative for all we know
it could be very friendly i don't know
but it and you can set up a dynamics
a markovian dynamics that is so called
stationary and that's a technical term
which means that the entropy effectively
is not increasing there is some entropy
but it's constant so there's no
increasing entropy
and in that sense
the dynamics is timeless
there is no entropic time
but it's a trivial theorem
three line proof
that if you have a stationary markovian
dynamics any projection that you make of
that dynamics by conditional probability
and if you want i can state a little bit
more even more mathematically precisely
for for some readers for listeners but
if any projection you take by
conditional probability
the induced
image of that markov chain
will have increasing entropy
you will have entropic time so so i'll
be very very precise i have
a mark of chain x1 x2 through xn where x
and n goes to infinity right
[Music]
the entropy h
capital h of xn is equal to the entropy
h of xn minus 1 for all n so the entropy
is the same
but
it's it's a theorem that h of x n
say given x sub 1
is greater than or equal to h of x n
minus 1
given x 1.
sure where does the greater come from
because with the theorem of three-line
proof
h of x n
x1
is greater than or equal to h of xn
given x1 and x2
because conditioning reduces
but then h of xn
minus 1
given
x1 comma x2
is equal to h of xn
um given x2 xn minus 1 given x2
by the markov property
and then because it's
stationary it's equal to
uh h of x um
um
i have to write it down next time sure
right anyway there's a three-line proof
sure
so
but the assumption of stationarity
we're using a lot of times that people
will understand right doesn't matter the
uh
so there's some kind of some markovian
dynamics is uh
basically trying to model some kind of
system with some probabilities and
there's agents and they interact in some
kind of way and you can say something
about that system as it involves uh
stationarity so a stationary
uh
system is one that has certain
properties in terms of entropy very well
but we don't know if it's stationary now
we don't know what properties
uh right uh you have to kind of take
assumptions and see okay well what is
what does the systems behave like
under these different properties the the
more constraints the more assumptions
you take the more predictive the more
interesting powerful things you can say
but sometimes the limiting
that said we're talking about
consciousness here
how does that you said cooperative okay
competitive
it just i like chocolate i'm sitting
here i have a brain i'm wearing a suit
it sure as hell feels like i'm myself
now what am i tuning in am i plugging
into something
am i a projection a simple trivial
projection into space-time from some
much larger organism that i can't
possibly comprehend how the hell you're
saying some yes you're building up
mathematical intuitions fine great but
i'm just i'm i'm having an existential
crisis here and i'm going to die soon
we'll all die pretty quickly so i i want
to
i want to figure out why chocolate is so
delicious
uh so help me out here so let's just
keep sneaking up to this
right so
the whole technical technical thing was
to say this
even if the dynamics of consciousness is
stationary so that there is no entropic
time
any
projection of it any
view of it
will have the artifact of entropic time
that's a limited resource
limited resources
so that the fundamental dynamics may
have no limits limited resources
whatsoever any projection will have
certainly time is a limited resource and
probably a lot of other limited
resources hence we could get
competition and evolution and nature red
and tooth and claw as an artifact of a
deeper system in which those aren't
fundamental and and in fact i take it as
something that this theory must do
at some point is to show how networks of
conscious agents even if they're not
resource limited give rise to evolution
by natural selection via a projection
yeah but you're saying
i'm trying to understand how the limited
resources that give rise to
um
so first the thing gives rise to time
that gives rise to limited resource that
gives rise to
evolution by natural selection how that
has to do with the fact that chocolate
is delicious
well well it's it's not going to do that
directly it's going to get to this
notion of self so oh oh it's going to
give you the notion of so evolution
gives you the notion of self
and also of of of a self separate from
other selves so so the idea would be
that competition has life and death all
those kinds of things that's right so it
it won't i i don't think
as i said i don't think that i can tell
you how the formless gives rise to the
experience of chocolate
right now my current theory says that's
that's one of the miracles i'm assuming
yeah that's so my theory can't do it and
the reason my theory can't do it is
because hoffman's brain can't do it
right now
[Laughter]
but but the notion of self
yes the notion of self can be an
artifact
of the projection
of a
so there's one conscious agent
because any time conscious agents
interact they form a new conscious agent
so there's one conscious agent any
projection of that one conscious agent
gives rise
to time even if there wasn't any time in
that one conscious agent
and it gives rise i i want to now i
haven't proven this so this is so now
this is me guessing where the theory is
going to go
not i haven't done this there's no paper
on this yet so now i'm speculating my
guess is i'll be able to show or the or
the my brighter colleagues working with
me will be able to show
that that we will get evolution of
natural selection the notion of
individual selves individual physical
objects and so forth coming out as a
projection of this thing and and that
the self
this then will be be really interesting
in terms of how it starts to interact
with certain
um spiritual traditions right where they
will say that there is a notion of self
that needs to be let go which is this
finite self that's competing with other
selves to you know get more money and
prestige and so forth that self in some
sense has to die but there's
a deeper self which is the timeless
um
being
that preclude that precedes not
precludes but precedes um any particular
conscious experiences the ground of all
experience that there's that notion of a
deep capital self but our little
capital lowercase s selves could be
artifacts of projection
and
it may be that
what consciousness is doing in this
framework is right it's it's projected
itself down
into a self that calls itself dawn and a
self that calls itself lacks
and
through conversations like this it's
trying to find out about itself
and eventually transcend
the limits of the don and lex
little icons that it's using
and and that little projection of itself
through this kind of conversation
somehow it it's learning about itself
so that that thing dressed me up today
in order to understand itself
and in some sense you and i are not
separate from that thing and we're not
separate from each other yeah
well i have to question the fashion
choices on my end then
all right so uh you mentioned you agree
on in terms of consciousness on
a lot of things with anika is there
somebody
friend
or friendly foe that you disagree with
in some nuanced interesting way or some
major way
about consciousness about these topics
of of reality that you return to
um often it's like uh uh
christopher hitchens with the rabbi
david walby
have had interesting conversations
through years that that added to the
complexity and the beauty of their
friendship is there is there somebody
like that
um that over the years has been a source
of disagreement with you that
strengthened your ideas
my ideas have been really
shaped by
several things
one is um
[Music]
the physicalist framework that
my scientific colleagues almost to a
person
have adopted and that i adopted to
until i the reason i walked away from it
was because i uh it became
clear that
we couldn't start with unconscious
ingredients and boot up consciousness
can you define physicalists
in contrast to reductionist
so a physicalist i i would
say is someone who takes space time and
the objects within space time as
ontologically fundamental
right and then reductionist is
saying the smaller the more fundamental
that's a methodological
thing that's that's saying within
space-time as you go to smaller and
smaller scales in space you get deeper
and deeper laws more and more
fundamental laws
and you know the reduction of
temperature to
particle movement was an example of that
but i think that that that
the reason that worked was
almost an artifact of the nature of our
interface
that was for a long time many of your
colleagues including yourself or
physicalist and now you broke away broke
away because i think you can't start
with unconscious ingredients and boot up
consciousness
and
so even with roger penrose where there's
like a gray area
right and here's the the challenge i
would put to to all of
my friends um and colleagues who are
give one specific conscious experience
that you can boot up
right so if you think that it's
integrated information
and this i've asked this
of julia to know me a couple times back
in the 90s and then just a couple years
ago i asked julio okay so great and
great information so
we're all interested in explaining some
specific conscious experiences so what
what is you know pick one the taste of
chocolate what is the integrated
information
[Music]
precise structure that we need for
chocolate and why does that structure
have to be
for chocolate and why
why is it that it could not possibly be
vanilla is there any elastomer is there
any one specific conscious experience
that you can account for because
notice they've set themselves the task
of booting up conscious experiences from
physical systems that's the test they've
set themselves but that doesn't mean
they're
uh i understand your intuition but that
doesn't mean they're wrong just because
they can't find a way to boot it up yet
that's right no that doesn't mean that
they're wrong it just just means that um
they haven't
done it i think it's principled
the reason is principled but but i'm
happy that they're exploring it but the
fact is the remarkable fact is there's
not one theory so integrated information
theory
collapse of microtubules
um global workspace
theory these are all theories of
consciousness these are all theories of
consciousness there's not a single
theory
that can give you a specific conscious
experience that they say here is the
physical dynamics or the physical
structure that must be the taste of
chocolate or whatever one they want so
you're saying it's impossible they're
saying it's just hard yeah
my attitude is okay
no one
said you had to start with neurons or
physical systems and boot up
consciousness you guys are just you
chose that problem so since you chose
that problem
how much progress have you made well
when you've not been able to come up
with a single specific conscious
experience
and you've had these brilliant people
working on it for decades now
that's not really good progress let me
ask you to be to play devil's advocate
can you try to steal man
steel man meaning argue
the best possible case for reality the
opposite of your book title so
um or maybe just sticking to
consciousness can you take the
physicalist view
can you steal man the physicalist view
for a brief moment playing devil's
advocate to or um steel man the person
you used to be
right the physicalist
what's the good
like saying that you might be wrong
right now
what would be a convincing
argument for that
well i think the
the
argument i would give and that i
believed was look when you have very
simple physical systems like
a piece of dirt there's not much
evidence of life for consciousness it's
only when you get really complicated
physical systems like that have brains
and really the more complicated the
brains the more it looks like
there's consciousness and the more
complicated that consciousness is
surely that means
that simple physical systems don't
create
much consciousness or if maybe not any
or maybe
pan cyclists they create the most
elementary kinds of simple conscious
experiences but you need
more complicated physical systems
to boot up
to create more complicated
consciousnesses i think that's the
intuition that drives most of my
colleagues and you're saying that this
concept of complexity
is ill-defined
when you ground it to space-time
well well i think it's well-defined
within the framework of space-time right
no it's
ill-defined relative to what you need to
actually understand consciousness
because you're grounding complexity in
just in space-time well got you right
right yeah yeah what i'm saying is
if it were true
that space-time was fundamental
then i would have to agree that if there
is such a thing as consciousness
given the data that we've got that you
know
complex brains have consciousness and
you know dirt doesn't
that somehow is the complexity of the
dynamics or organization
the function of the physical system that
somehow is creating the consciousness
um
so
under those assumptions
yes but when the physicists themselves
are telling us that space time is not
fundamental
then i can understand see then the whole
picture starts to come into focus
why my colleagues are brilliant
right
these are really smart people i mean
francis crick worked on this for the
last 20 years of his life
these are not stupid people these are
brilliant brilliant people the fact that
we've come up with not a single specific
conscious experience that we can explain
and no hope there's there's no one that
says i'm really close so i'll have it
for you in a year no
there's just like
there's this fundamental gap
so much so that steve pinker in in one
of his writings says look
he likes the global
workspace theory but he says the last
dollop of the theory in which you know
there's something it's like to
he said we may have to just stipulate
that as a as a brute fact
i mean he
that's i mean that one and pinker is
brilliant right he he's he understands
the state of play
on this problem of the hard problem of
consciousness starting with physicalist
assumptions and then trying to boot up
consciousness and you've set yourself
the problem i'm starting with physical
stuff that's not that's not conscious
i'm trying to get the taste of chocolate
out
as maybe some kind of function of that
of the dynamics of that
we've not been able to do that and so
pinker is saying we may have to punt
we may have to just stipulate that last
bit he calls it the last dollop um and
just say stipulate it as a bare fact of
nature that there is something it's like
well
from my point of view as the physical
the whole point the whole promise of the
physicalist was we wouldn't have to
stipulate i was going to start with the
physical stuff and explain where the
consciousness came from if i'm going to
stipulate consciousness why don't i just
stipulate consciousness and not
stipulate all the physical stuff too so
i'm stipulating less i'm saying okay i
agree
perspective well it's it's actually what
i call the conscious realist perspective
consciousness
pan cyclists are effectively duelists
right they're saying there's physical
stuff that really is fundamental
and then consciousness stuff so i would
go with pinker and say look let's just
stipulate the consciousness stuff but
i'm not going to stipulate the physical
stuff i'm going to actually now show how
to boot up the physical stuff from just
the consciousness stuff
so i'll stipulate less is it possible so
if you stipulate less is it possible for
our limited brains to visualize reality
as we
delve deeper and deeper and deeper
is it possible to visualize somehow with
the tools of math with the tools of
computers with the tools of our mind are
we hopelessly lost
you said there's ways to intuit
what's true
using mathematics and
probability
and um
sort of uh
markovian dynamics all that kind of
stuff but that's not visualizing that's
what's the kind of
building intuition but is it possible to
visualize in the way we visualize so
nicely in in space time in four
dimensions in two in three dimensions
sorry well two we really are looking
through a two-dimensional screen until
what we intuit to be a three-dimensional
world
and and also inferring dynamic stuff
making it 4d anyway is it possible to
visualize some pretty pictures that give
us a deeper sense of the truth of
reality
i think that we will
incrementally be able to do that
i think that for example
the picture that we have of
electrons and photons interacting
and scattering
wasn't
it may have not been possible until
faraday did all of his experiments and
then maxwell wrote down his equations
and and we were then sort of forced by
his equations to think in a new way
and then then when planck in 1900
you know
desperate to try to solve the
the problem of black body radiation that
what they call the ultraviolet
catastrophe where newton was predicting
infinite
energies where there weren't infinite
energies in black body radiation
and he in desperation
proposed
packets of energy the
then once once you've done that
and then you have an einstein come along
five years later and show how that
explains the photoelectro
photoelectric effect and then
then eventually in 1926 you get quantum
theory and then you get this whole new
way of thinking that was
you know from the newtonian point of
view completely
contradictory and and were
counter-intuitive certainly
yeah
and maybe if jesus is right not
contradictory maybe if you use
intuitionist math they're not
contradictory but still
certainly you wouldn't have gone there
and so here's a case where the
experiments
and then a desperate mathematical move
sort of we
use those as a flashlight into the deep
fog
right where and and so that science may
be
um
the flashlight into the deep fog
yeah i wonder if it's still possible to
visualize in the in the deli like uh we
talk about consciousness in
from a self perspective experience that
hold that idea in our mind the way you
can experience things directly we've
evolved to experience things
in this
3d world
and it's that's a very rich experience
when you're thinking mathematically
[Music]
you still in the end of the day have to
project it down
to a
low dimensional space to make
to make conclusions their conclusions
will be a number
or a line
or plot
or a
so i wonder like how we can really touch
some deep truth
in this in a subjective way like
experience it really feel the beauty of
it you know in the way that humans feel
beauty
right are we screwed
i don't think we're screwed i think that
we get little hints of it from
from
psychedelic drugs and so forth we get
hints that there are certain
interventions that we can take on our
interface
i apply this chemical which is
just some element of my interface to
this other
to a brain i ingest it and all of a
sudden
i seem like i've opened new portals into
conscious experiences
well that's very very suggestive that's
like um the black body radiation doing
something that we didn't expect right it
doesn't go to infinity when we thought
it was going to go to infinity and we're
forced to
propose these quanta
so
once we have a theory of conscious
agents
and this projection is based on i should
say i should sketch what i think that
projection is um
but then i think
we can then start to ask specific
questions when when you're taking
dmt
or you're taking
lsd or something like that
now that we have this deep model that
we've reverse engineered space and time
and physical particles we've pulled them
back to this theory of conscious agents
now we can ask ourselves in this
idealized future
um
what are we doing to conscious agents
when we
apply 5mo dmt what are we doing
are we opening a new portal
right so when i say that i mean i have a
portal into consciousness that i call my
body of lex friedman that i'm creating
and it's a genuine portal not perfect
but it's a genuine portal i'm definitely
communicating with your consciousness
and we know that we have
one technology
for building new portals
we know one technology and that is
having kids
having kids is how we
build new portals into consciousness
it takes a long time can you elaborate
that oh oh oh you mean like
your son and your daughter didn't exist
that was a portal though you're having
contact with consciousness that you
never would have had before but now
you've got a son or a daughter you had
you went through this physical process
they were born then you
there was all the but is that portal
yours
so when you have kids are you creating
new portals that are completely distinct
from the portals that you've created
with other consciousness like can you
can you elaborate on that to which
degree is are the consciousness of your
kids
a part of you
well so every person that i see
that symbol that i see the body that i
see
is is a portal
potentially for me to interact with with
a consciousness yeah
um and
and each consciousness has a unique
character and we call it a personality
right and so forth so
with each new kid that's born we come in
contact with a personality that
we've never seen before and a
version of consciousness that we've
never seen before at a deeper level as i
said the theory says there's one agent
so this is a different projection
of that one agent
but but
so that's what i mean by a portal is
within my own interface my own
projection
can i
see other projections
of of that one consciousness so can i
get portals in in that sense and i
so and i think i think we will get a
theory of that that we will get a theory
of portals and then we can ask how the
psychedelics
are acting are they actually creating
new portals or not
if they're not
we should nevertheless then understand
how we could create a new portal right
maybe we have to just study what happens
when we make when we have kids
we know that that technology creates new
portals
so we have to reverse engineer that and
then say okay could we somehow
create
new portals de novo with that
uh
like uh brain computer interfaces for
example yeah so maybe just a chemical or
something else probably more complicated
than a chemical that's why i think that
the psychedelics the psychedelics may
because they might be affecting this
portal in certain ways that it turns it
around and opens up
in other words it may be once we
understand what this thing is important
your body as a portal and understand all
those complexities maybe we'll realize
that that portal can be shifted and into
different parts of the the deeper
consciousness and give new windows on it
and so in that way maybe yes
psychedelics could open up new portals
in the sense that they're taking
something that's already a complex
portal and just tweaking it a bit
well but creating is a very powerful
difference between morphing
right right tweaking versus creating i
agree
but maybe it gives you intuition to at
least the full space of the kinds of
things that this particular system is
capable of i mean i mean the idea your
idea the consciousness creates brains i
mean
that breaks my brain because
because i you know i'm i'm i guess i'm
still a physicalist in that sense
because that you could
it's just much easier
to intuit the world
um it's very it's practical to think all
right there's a neural network and
what are the different ways fascinating
uh capabilities can emerge from this
neural network uh
it's free it's easier and so you start
to
and then present to yourself the problem
of okay well how does consciousness
arise how does intelligence arise
how does
emotion arise
how does
memory arise in the
how do we filter within the system all
the incoming sensory information we're
able to
uh allocate attention in different
interesting ways how do all those
mechanisms arise
to say that there's other fundamental
things we don't understand outside of
space-time that are actually core to how
this whole thing works
is uh is a bit paralyzing because
it's like oh
we're not we're not ten percent done
we're like zero point zero zero one
percent done
it's the f is it's the immediate feeling
certainly understand that my attitude
about it is
if you look at the young physicists
who are searching for the instructors
beyond space time like amplitude and so
forth
they're having a ball
space time that's what the old folks did
that's what that's what our the older
generation did
we're we're doing something that really
is fun and new
and and
they're having a blast and they're
finding all all these new structures so
so i i think that we're going to um
succeed
in
getting a new deeper theory i can just
say what i'm hoping with the theory that
i'm working on i'm hoping to show that i
could have this timeless dynamics of
consciousness no entropic time
i take a projection and i show how this
timeless dynamics looks like the big
bang
and the entire evolution of space-time
in other words i see how my whole space
time interface
so not just the uh the projections just
doesn't just look like space-time you
can explain
the whole with it the whole from the
origin of the universe that's that's
what we have to do and that's what the
physicists understand when they go
beyond space time to the amplitude and
the cosmological polytube they
ultimately know that they have to get
back the big bang story and the whole
evolution that whole story where there
were no living things there was just
a point and then the explosion and then
just particles at high energy and then
eventually the cooling down and the
differentiation and finally
matter
condenses and then life and then
consciousness that whole story has to
come out of something that's deeper and
without time and that's what what we're
up to that's we we want to to get this
so the whole story that we've we've been
telling ourselves about big bang and how
brains evolved in unconsciousness will
come out of a much deeper theory and and
for yeah for someone like me um
it's a lot i mean
but for the younger generation
this is like oh wow
um all the low cherries aren't picked
this is really good stuff this is really
new fundamental stuff that we can do so
that i can't wait to read the papers of
the of the younger generation and i want
to i want to see them
uh kids these days with their non-space
time assumptions
uh it's just interesting looking at the
philosophical tradition of this
difficult ideas you struggle with if you
look like somebody
like
emmanuel kant what are some interesting
agreements and disagreements you
have uh with a guy about the nature of
reality
so there's a lot in agreement right so
kant was an idealist
transcendental ideas and
he he basically had the idea that um
we don't see nature as it is we impose
the structure on nature
he
and and so in some sense i'm saying
something similar i'm saying that by the
way i don't call myself an idealist i
call myself a conscious realist because
idealism has a long history a lot of
different
ideas come under idealism and there's a
lot of debates and so forth it this
tends to be identified with in many
cases anti-science and anti-realism
and i don't want either connection with
my ideas and so i just called mine
conscious realism with an emphasis on
realism
and not and not anti-realism
but but the one place where i would of
course disagree with kant was that he
thought that um
euclidean
space time was a priori
right we just know that that's false
so so he he went went to too far
on that but
but in in general the idea that we don't
start with space time that space and
time is in some sense forms of our
perceptions yes absolutely
and
i would say that
you know there's a lot in common with
barclay in that regard
there's a lot of ingenious arguments in
barclay
leibniz
leibniz in his monodology
understood very clearly that the hard
problem was not solvable
he posed a hard problem and basically
dismissed it and just you can't do this
and so if he came here he
and saw where we are he said look guys i
told you this 300 years ago and he had
his momentology he was trying
to do something like this it's
um
it's different from what i'm doing but
he had these things that were not in
space and time the these moan ads he was
trying to build something
um
i'm trying to build a theory of
conscious agents my guess is that if
he came here i could just
if he saw what i was doing he would say
he would understand it and immediately
take off with it and go places that i
couldn't he he would he would so there
would be
right there would be overlap of uh the
spirit of the ideas absolutely totally
overlapping but his genius would then
just run with it far faster than i could
i love the humility here
so let me ask you about sort of
practical implications of your ideas to
our world our complicated world when you
look at the big questions of humanity of
hate
war
what else is there evil
maybe there's the positive aspects of
that
of meaning of love
um what is the fact that
reality is an illusion
perceived
what what is the conscious realism
when applied to daily life what kind of
impact does it have a lot and it's it's
sort of scary
um
we all know that life is
ephemeral and spiritual traditions have
said wake up to the fact that you know
anything that you do here is going to
disappear
but it's even more ephemeral than
perhaps we've thought i see this bottle
because i create it right now as soon as
i look away
that data structure has been garbage
collected that bottle
i have to recreate it every time i look
so i spend all my money i buy this fancy
car
that car i have to keep recreating it
every time i look at it it's that
ephemeral
so all the things that we
invest ourselves in we fight over we
kill each other over and we have wars
over
these are all it's just like people in a
virtual reality simulation
right and and there's this this porsche
and we all see the porsche well
where that porsche exists when i look at
it i turn my headset and i look at it
and
and then if joe turns his headset in the
right way he'll see his porsche it's not
it's not even the same portion that i
see he's creating his own porsche
so these things are exceedingly
ephemeral and and now
just imagine
saying that that's my porsche well
you can agree to say that it's your
portion but but really the porsche only
exists as long as you
look
so so this all of a sudden what the
spiritual traditions have been saying
for a long long time this gets cashed
out in in mathematically precise science
it's saying in femoral yes in fact it
lasts for a few milliseconds a few
hundred milliseconds while you look at
it and then it's gone so so the whole
idea
why are we fighting why do we hate it's
we fight over possessions
because we we think that we're small
little objects
inside this
pre-existing space time we assume that
that that mansion and that car
exists
independent of us and that somehow
we these little things can have our
sense of
self and importance enhanced by having
that special car or that special house
or that special person
when in fact
is just the opposite
you create that mansion every time you
look
that's that's
you're the you're something far deeper
than that mansion you're the
entity which can create that mansion on
the fly and there's nothing there
there's nothing to the mansion except
what you create in this moment so all so
all of a sudden
when you take this point of view
it has all sorts of implications
for how we interact with each other how
how we treat each other
um
and again a lot of things that spiritual
traditions have said
it's a mixed bag spiritual traditions
are a mixed bag so let me just be right
up front about that i'm not promoting
any particular but they do have some
insights yeah they have wisdom they have
certain wisdom they have i can point to
nonsense i won't go into it but i can
also point to lots of nonsense so so the
the issue is to then to look for the key
the key insights and they i think they
have
a lot of insights about
the ephemeral nature of of objects in
space and time and not being attached to
them including our own bodies
and reversing that i'm not this little
thing
a little consciousness trapped in the
body and the consciousness itself is
only a product of the body so when the
body dies the consciousness disappears
it turns completely around the
consciousness is fundamental the body
my hand exists right now because i'm
looking at it my hand is gone
i have no hand i have i have no brain i
have no heart if you looked you'll see a
heart
whatever i am
[Music]
is this really complicated thing in
consciousness that's that's what i am
all the stuff that i thought i was
is something that i create on the fly
and delete so this whole so this is
completely
a radical restructuring of how we think
about
possessions
about identity
about
survival of death
and and so forth this is completely
transformative
but the nice thing is that
this whole approach of conscious
stations
unlike the spiritual traditions which
have said
in some cases similar things
they set it in precisely
this is mathematics
we can actually now begin to stay
precisely here's the mathematical model
of consciousness conscious agents here's
how it maps onto spacetime which i
should
sketch really briefly
and here's why
things are ephemeral
and here's why you shouldn't be worried
about the ephemeral nature of things
because
you're not a little tiny entity inside
space and time
quite the opposite you're the author of
space and time
the i and the am and the i am is all
kind of emerging through this whole
process of evolution and so on
that's
that's just surface waves and there's a
much deeper ocean that we're trying to
figure out here so how does you said
this said this some of the stuff you're
thinking about maps the space time how
does it map the space right so so just a
very very high level and i'll keep it
brief
the structures that the physicists are
finding
like the amplitude
it turns out they're just static
structure they're polytopes
but they
remarkably most of the information in
them is contained in permutation
matrices
so it's a matrix like an n by n matrix
that just has zeros and ones
that contains almost all of the
information and you can they have these
plabic graphs and so forth that they use
to boot up
the scattering you can compute those
scattering amplitudes
almost entirely from these
permutation matrices
so that's just
now from my point of view i have this
conscious agent dynamics
it turns out that the stationary
dynamics
that i was talking about the the where
the entropy is increasing
all the stationary dynamics are
sketched out by
permutation matrices
so if you there's so-called burkhoff
polytope
all the vertices of this polytube all
the points
are permutation matrices all the
internal
points are markovian kernels
um
that have the uniform measure as a
stationary measure i need to intuit a
little better with what the heck you're
talking about but
so basically there's some complicated
thing going on with the network of
conscience
conscious agents and that's mappable to
this
you're saying a two-dimensional matrix
that uh
uh scattering has to do with what with
our perception like that's like photon
stuff or i mean i don't know if it's
useful to sort of
uh dig into detail i'll do just a high
level thing yes
so the the the high level is the
long-term behavior of the conscious
agent that makes so that's the
projection of just looking at the
long-term behavior
i'm hoping will give rise to the
amplitude
the amplitude
then gives rise to space-time
so then i can just use their link to go
all the way from consciousness through
its asymptotics
to through the amplitude into space time
and get the map all the way
into our interface and that's why you
mentioned the permutation majors because
it gives you a nice thing to to try to
generate that's right it's the
connection with the amplitude the
permutation matrices are the core of the
amplitude and it turns out they're the
core of the asymptotic description of
the conscious agents
so not to sort of bring up the idea of a
creator but i i like
first of all i like video games and you
mentioned
this kind of simulation idea first of
all do you think of as an interesting
idea this thought experiment that will
live in a simulation
and in general do you think we live in a
simulation
so the nick bostrom's idea about the
simulation is typically
couched in a physicalist framework yes
so there's the bottom level
there's some programmer in this physical
spacetime and they have a computer that
they've programmed really cleverly where
they've created
conscious entities
so you have the hard problem of
consciousness right the standard hard
problem how could a computer simulation
create a constant
which isn't explained by that simulation
theory but then the idea is that the
next level the the entities that are
from the
that are
created in the first level simulation
then can write their own simulations and
you get this this nesting
so
so the idea that um this is a simulation
is fine
but the idea that this starts with a
physical space i think
isn't but there's there's different
properties here the the partial
rendering and to me that's
the interesting idea
is not whether the entirety of the
universe is simulated but how
efficiently can you
create interfaces that are convincing to
all
other entities that can appreciate such
interfaces how little does it take
because you said like partial rendering
or like temporal
affirmative rendering of stuff
only render the tree falling in the
forest when there's somebody there to
see it
it's interesting
to think how can you do that super
efficiently without having to render
everything and that to me is one
perspective on the simulation just like
it is with video games right where a
video game doesn't have to render every
single thing it's just the thing that
the observer is looking at right there
is actually that's a
very nice question and there's
whole groups of researchers that are
actually studying in virtual reality
what
what is the sort of minimal
requirements on this system what how
does it have to operate to give you an
immersion experience to give you the
feeling that you have a body to to get
you to take it real and there's actually
a lot of really good work on that right
now and it turns out it doesn't take
that much you do need to get the
perception action loop
tight and and
you have to
give them the perceptions that they're
expecting if you want them to but if you
you you can
lead them along if you give them
perceptions that are close to what
they're expecting you can then maybe
move their reality around a bit yeah
it's a tricky engineering problem
especially when you're trying to create
a product
that costs little but that's i it feels
like an engineering problem not a deeply
scientific problem
or meaning obviously it's a scientific
problem but as a scientific problem it's
not that difficult to trick us
uh descendants of apes but here's here's
a
case for just us you know our own this
is a virtual reality that we're
experiencing right now so
here's something you can try for
yourself
if you just close your eyes
and look at
your experience in front of you to be
aware of your experience in front of you
what you experience is just like a
modeled
dark gray but there's all sort of
there's some dynamics to it but it's
just dark gray
but now i ask you
instead of having your attention
forward
put your attention backward what is it
like behind you with your eyes closed
and there
it's like
nothing
it's real
so
what is going on here what
what am i experiencing back there
right well it's it's i i don't know if
it's nothing it's it's like i guess it's
the absence of it's not even like
darkness or something it's it even it's
not even darkness
there's no there's no
qualia
and yet there is a sense of being
and that's the interesting thing there's
a sense of being back so i close my
if i put my attention forward i just i
have the quality of a gray model thing
but when i put my attention backward
there's no quality at all but there is a
sense of being yeah
i i personally
uh now you haven't been to that side of
the room i have been to that side of the
room so for me memories i start
um i start
playing the engine of memory replay
which is like i i take myself back in
time and think about that place where i
was hanging out in that part that's what
i see when i'm behind so which that's an
interesting quirk of hum humans too
we're able to we're collecting these
experiences and we can replay them in
interesting ways whenever we feel like
it and it's almost like being there
but not really but almost
that's right
and yet we can go our entire lives on
this you're talking about the minimal
thing for vr we can go our entire lives
and not realize that all of my life
it's been like nothing behind me
yeah
we we we're not even aware that all of
our lives
if you just just for the just pay
attention close your eyes pay attention
to what's behind me we're like oh holy
smoke it's totally scary i mean it's
like nothing there's no quality there at
all how did i not notice that my entire
life we're so immersed in the simulation
we buy it so much yeah i mean uh you
could see this with with children right
with persistence you know you could do
the peekaboo game you can hide from them
and appear
and they're fully tricked and in the
same way we're fully tricked
there's nothing behind us and we assume
there is
that's really interesting these theories
are pretty heavy
you as a human being
as a mortal human being
how has
these theories been to you personally
like are there good days and bad days
when you wake up and look in the mirror
and the fact that you can't see anything
behind you
the fact that it's rendered like is
there interesting quirks
you know you know nietzsche with his if
you gaze long into the abyss the abyss
gazes into you
um how's this theories these ideas
change you as a person
it's been very very difficult
this stuff is not just abstract
theory building because it's about us
sometimes i realize that there's this
big division of me my my mind is doing
all this science and and coming up with
these conclusions and the rest of me is
not integrating i was just like i don't
believe it i just don't believe this i
mean it seems so as i start to take it
seriously it's get i get scared myself
it's like
but it's very much then i read these
spiritual traditions and realize they're
saying very very similar things it's
like there's a lot of conversions so for
me
i
have
the first time i thought
it might be possible that we're not
seeing the truth
was in
it was from some mathematics we were
doing
and
when that hit me it hit me like a ton of
bricks i had to sit down it was
it it really
it was scary it was really a shock to
the system and then to realize that
everything that has been important to me
like
you know
getting a house
getting a car
getting a reputation and so forth
well that car is just like the car i see
in the virtual reality it's there when
you perceive it it's not there
so
the whole question of you know what am i
doing and why what what's what's
worthwhile doing in life
clearly
getting a big house and getting a big
car
i mean we all knew that we were going to
die
so we we
we we tend not to know that we tend to
hide it especially when we were young
before age 30 we don't believe we're
going to die yeah we factually maybe
know that you're you kind of are
supposed to yeah but but they'll figure
something out and yeah we'll be the
generation that is the first one that
doesn't have to die
that's the kind of thing but but when
you really face the fact that
you're going to die
and then when you when i start to look
at it from this point of view that well
this thing was an interface to begin
with so what i'm really is what i'm
really going to be doing
just taking off a headset so i've been
playing in a virtual reality game all
day and i i got lost in the game when i
was fighting over a porsche and i i shot
some guys up and i punctured their tires
and i got the porsche now i take the
headset off and what was that for
nothing there was just it was a data
structure and the data structure is gone
so so all of the wars the fighting and
the reputations and all this stuff you
know
where it's just a headset
so now and you know so my theory says
that intellectually
my my
mind my my emotions
rebel all over the place this is like i
you know
and so so i have to imagine i meditate a
lot well what percent of the day would
you say you spend as a physicalist
um
sort of living life pretending your car
matters
your reputation matter like
like how much uh was that tom wait song
i like my town with a little drop of
poison how much poison do you allow
yourself to have i think my default mode
is physicalist right i think that that's
just the default i i
when i'm not
being conscious
yeah consciously attentive
intellectually consciously because if
you're just you're still if you're
tasting coffee and not thinking or
drinking or just taking in the sunset
you're not being intellectual you're but
you're still experiencing it right so
it's when you turn on the like the
introspective machine that's when you
can start and turn off the thinker when
i actually just start looking without
thinking
so that's that's when i feel like i
all of a sudden i'm starting to see
through
sort of like okay
part of
part of the addiction to the interface
is all the stories i'm telling about
it's really important for me to get that
really important
to do that all so i'm telling all these
stories and so i'm all wrapped up
almost all the mind stuff that's going
on in my head is about
attachment to the interface
and so what i found
is that
the
essentially the only way to really
detach from the interface
is to
[Music]
literally let go of thoughts altogether
and then all of a sudden
um
even my identity of you know my whole
history my name my education all this
stuff
is almost irrelevant because it's just
now
here is the present moment
and this is this is the reality right
now and all of that other stuff is an
interface story
but this conscious experience right now
this is the only
this is the only reality as far as i can
tell
the rest of it's a story
and
but that is again
not my default that is i have to make a
really
conscious choice to say okay i know
intellectually this is all an interface
i i'm going to take the headset off and
so forth
and and and then immediately sink back
into the game and just
be out there playing the game and get
lost in so i'm always lost in the game
unless i
literally consciously choose
to stop thinking
isn't it terrifying
to acknowledge that
to look beyond the game
isn't it uh
scares the hell out of me
it really is scary
because i'm so attached i'm attached to
this body i'm attached to the interface
are you ever worried about breaking your
brain
a bit
meaning like
it's uh
i mean some of these ideas when you
think about reality even with like
einstein
just realizing you said interface just
realizing that
light
you know that there's a speed of light
and you can't go fast in the speed of
light and like what kind of things black
holes and
can do with light even that can mess
with your head
yes
but that's still space time
that's a big mess but it's still just
space-time it's still a property over
interface that's right but it's still
like even so
even einstein realized that this
particular thing some of the stories we
tell ourselves is constructing
interfaces
that are
oversimplifying the way things work
because the it's nice the stories are
nice
stories are nice this rep i mean just
like video games they're nice
right and but einstein was a realist
right he was a famous realist in this in
the sense that he he
was very explicit in a 1935 paper with
um podesta and rosen the epr paper where
he
they said
if without
in any way
disturbing a system
i can predict with probability one
the outcome of a measurement
then there exists in reality
that element
right that that value that
and we now know from quantum theory that
that that's false
that einstein's idea of local realism is
is strictly speaking false
yeah and and so we can predict we can
set up in quantum theory you can set up
and there's a there's a paper by chris
fuchs quantum basianism
where he
he scouts this out it was done by other
people but he gives a good presentation
of this where they have a sequence of
like something like nine different
quantum measurements that that you can
make
and
you can predict with probability one
what a particular outcome will be but
you can actually prove
that it's impossible
that the
value existed before you made the
measurement so you know with probability
one what you're going to get but you
also know with certainty that that value
was not there until you made the
measurement so the so we know from
quantum theory that the act of
observation is an act of fact creation
and that is
built into what i'm saying with this
theory of consciousness if consciousness
is fundamental
space time itself is an act of fact
creation it's it's an interface that we
create consciousness creates plus all
the objects in it so local realism
is not true
quantum theory is established also
non-contextual realism is not true
and that that it fits in perfectly with
this idea that consciousness is
fundamental
these things are these exist as data
structures when we create them
as as as chris says the act of
observation is an active fact creation
but i must say on a personal level
i'm having
to spend
i spend a couple hours a day
just sitting in meditation on this
and
facing
the rebellion
in me that goes to the co it feels like
it goes to the core of my being
rebellion against these ideas so so here
is very very interesting for me to look
at this because so here i'm a scientist
and i'm a person
the science is really clear
local realism is false non-contextual
realism is false space time is doomed
it's very very clear it couldn't be
clear
and my my emotions rebel left and right
when i sit there and say okay i am not
something in space and time
then something inside of me says
you're crazy of course you are and i'm
completely attached to it i'm completely
attached to all this stuff i'm attached
to my body i'm attached to the headset
i'm attached to my car
attached to people i'm attached to all
of it
and and yet i know as a absolute fact
i'm going to walk away from all of it
i'm going to die
it'll you know
in fact i almost died last year i mean
covet almost killed me it i i i sent a
goodbye text to my wife so i was
i thought you really did i sent her a
goodbye i thought i was in the emergency
room
and uh it had attacked my heart
and it been at 190 beats per minute for
36 hours
like i couldn't last much longer i knew
i could they couldn't stop it
so
that was that was it so that was it so
so i texted her goodbye from the
emergency room
i love you goodbye kind of thing
yeah right yeah that was it so so were
you afraid
yeah i was scared to help you right but
there there is there was
you're just feeling so bad anyway that
that all you know you that's sort of
what you're scared but you're just
feeling so bad that in some sense you
just wanted to stop anyway yeah
so so i've i've been there
and faced it just just a year ago
how did that change you by the way
having having this intellectual reality
that's so challenging that you meditate
on that you're it's just an interface
and one of the
one of the hardest things to come to
terms with is that that means that you
know
it's going to end
um
how did i change you having come so
close to the reality of it it's not just
an intellectual reality it's
it's a reality of death
it's it's forced i've meditated for 20
years now
and then i would say averaging three or
four hours a day
um
but it's put a new
urgency
but is it urgency is not the right word
because that that
it's it
it's riveted my attention i'll put it
that way it's really riveted my
attention and um
i've really paid
i spent a lot more time looking at what
spiritual traditions say
i don't by the way
again not taking it with the you know
i take it all with a grain of salt but
on the other hand i think it's stupid
for me to ignore it so i try to listen
to
the best ideas
and and to sort out
nonsense from
and it's just we all have to do it for
ourselves right it's not easy so what
makes sense
and i have the advantage of some science
so i can look at what science says and
try to compare with spiritual tradition
i try to sort it out for myself
and
but then i also look and realize that
there's another aspect to me which is
this whole emotional aspect
the
i i seem to be wired up
as
evolutionary psychology says i'm wired
up
right
all these defensive mechanisms you know
i'm inclined to lie if i need to i'm
inclined to
to be angry to protect myself to have an
in-group and an out group
to try to
make my reputation as big as possible to
try to demean the out group there's all
these things that evolutionary
psychology is is spot on it's really
brilliant about the human condition
and yet i think evolution
as i said evolutionary theory
is a projection of a deeper theory where
there may be no competition
so how so i'm in this very interesting
position
where i feel like okay according to my
own theory i'm consciousness and maybe
this is what it means for consciousness
to wake up it's not easy
it's it's
it's almost like i have i feel like i
have real skin in the game
it really is scary i really was scared
when i was about to die
it really was hard to say goodbye to my
wife it really it really pained
and
to then look at that and then look at
the fact that
i'm going to walk away from this anyway
and it's just an interface how do i so
it's it's trying to put all this stuff
together and really
grok it so to speak not just
intellectually but rocket
at an emotion yeah what are you afraid
of you silly evolved organism that's
gotten way too attached to the interface
what are you really afraid of that's
right
is there uh very personal you know it's
very very personal yeah yeah
i mean speaking of the text what do you
think is uh this whole love thing
what's the role of love in our
human condition
this interface thing we have this is
this somehow interweaved interconnected
with consciousness this attachment we
have to other humans and this deep like
some um
there's some quality to it
that seems very
interesting peculiar
well
there are two levels i would think about
that there there's love in the sexual
sense and there's love in a deeper sense
and in the sexual sense um we can give
an evolutionary account of that and and
so forth and i think that's pretty clear
to people
um
in in in this deeper sense
right so of course
you're married you're i love my wife in
a sexual sense but there's a deeper
sense as well that when i was saying
goodbye to her there was a there was a
deeper much deeper love that was really
at play there that's one place where i
think
that the mixed bag from spiritual
traditions has something right when they
say you know love your neighbor as
yourself that that some in some sense
love is fundamental
i think that they're on to something
something very very deep and profound
and
every most of all i can get a personal
glimpse of that when i especially when
i'm in the
space with no thought
right when when i can really let go of
thoughts
i get little glimpses of
of a love in the sense that i'm not
separate
it's a it's a love in the sense that i'm
not
different from that i you know
yeah if you are separate then then
there's i can fight you but if you and i
are the same
if there's a union there the
togetherness of it yeah what what uh
who's god
all those gods the stories that been
told throughout history you said through
the spiritual traditions
what do you think that is is that us
trying to find that
common
thing at the core
oh well in in many
traditions not all
the one i was raised in so my dad was a
protestant minister
we tend to think of god
as a being
but i think that
that's not right
i think
the closest way to think about god is
being period not a being but
being
the very ground of being itself is god i
think that's the
the deep and from my point of view
that's the ground of consciousness so
the ground of conscious being is
what we might call god but but the word
god has always been you know for example
you don't believe the same god as my god
so i'm going to fight you or i will
we'll have wars over because
the being the specific being that you
call god is different from the being
that i call god and so we fight whereas
if it's
not a being but just being and you and i
share being then you and i are are not
separate and there's no reason to fight
we're both part of that one being and
and
loving you is loving myself because
we're all part of that one being
the spiritual traditions that point to
that
i think are pointing
it in a very interesting direction and
that does seem to
match with the mathematics of the
conscious agent stuff that i've been
working on as well that
it really fits with that although that
wasn't my goal
is there uh you mentioned
you mentioned that the young physicists
that um you talk to or whose work you
follow
have quite a lot of fun breaking with
the traditions of the past the
assumptions of the past
uh what advice would you give to young
people today in high school and college
not just physicists but uh
in general how to have a career they can
be proud of how they can have a life
they can be proud of
how to make their way in the world from
the lessons
from the wins and the losses in your own
life what what what little insights
could you pull out
i would say
the universe is a lot more interesting
than you might expect
and you
are a lot more special and interesting
than you might expect you might think
that you're just a little
tiny
irrelevant
100 pound 200 pound
person in a vast billions of light years
across space
and that's not the case
you are in some sense the being that's
creating that space all the time every
time you look
so
waking up to who you really are
outside of space and time
as the author of space and time is the
author of everything that you see
the author of space and time
sorry you're the author of space and
time right
and i'm the author of space and time and
space and time is just one little data
structure many other consciousnesses are
creating other other data structures
they're authors of various other things
so so realizing and then realizing that
that um
i had this feeling that growing up and
going and called
reading all these textbooks oh man it's
all been done
yeah
if i'd just been there you know 50 years
ago i could have discovered this stuff
but the you know it's all in the
textbooks now
well
believe me the textbooks are going to
look silly in 50 years
and it's your chan your chance to write
the new textbook so so
of course study the current textbooks
you have to understand them you there's
no way to progress until you understand
what's been done
but but then
the only limit is your imagination
frankly that's the only limit the
greatest books the greatest textbooks
ever written on earth are yet to be
written exactly
uh
what do you think is the meaning of this
whole thing what's the meaning of life
from your limited interface can you can
you can you figure it all out like why
why so you said the universe is kind of
trying to figure itself out through
through us
uh why why
yeah that's the closest i've come so
i'll give you so i
will say that i don't know but but but
i'll here's my guess right that's a good
first sentence that's a good starting
point and and maybe that's
going to be a profound part of the final
answer is to start with the i don't know
it's quite possible that that
that's really important to start with
the i don't know
my guess is that if consciousness is
fundamental
and of girdle girdles and completeness
theorem
holds here
and there's infinite variety of
structures
for consciousness to some sense explore
um
that maybe that's
what it's about this is something that
anika and i talked about a little bit
and she doesn't like this way of talking
about it so i'm gonna have to talk with
some more about this way of talking but
right now i'll just put it this way and
i'll have to talk with her more and see
if i can say it more clearly
but the way i
i'm talking about it now is that
there's a sense in which
there's being
and then there's the experiences or
forums that come out of being
that's one deep deep mystery
and
the the question of that you asked what
is it all about somehow it's related to
that why does being
why does it just stay without any forms
why does it
why don't why do we have experiences
what why should why why not just have
when you close your eyes and you pay
attention to what's behind you there's
nothing
but there's being
why is why don't we just stop there why
didn't we just stop there why did we
create all tables and chairs and the sun
and moon and people
that all this really complicated stuff
why
and and
all i can guess right now
and i'll probably kick myself in a
couple years and say that was dumb but
but all i can guess right now is that
somehow
consciousness wakes up to itself by
knowing what it's not
so here i am i'm not this body
and i sort of saw that
it was sort of in my face when i
sent a text goodbye but then as soon as
i'm better it's sort of like okay i i
sort of don't want to go there right
okay so i just so
i am my body you know about my go back
to the standard thing i own my body and
you know and then i want to get that car
and even though i was just about to die
a year ago so
that comes rushing back so
so consciousness immerses itself
fully
into
a particular headset
gets lost in it
and then slowly wakes up just so it can
escape and that is the waking up but he
needs to have needs to know what is not
it needs to to know what you are
you have to say oh i'm not that i'm not
that that wasn't important that wasn't
important
that's really powerful don let me just
say that um
because i've been a long term fan of
yours and we're supposed to have a
conversation during this very difficult
moment in your life let me just say
you're truly special person and i for
one and i know there's a lot a lot of
others that agree i'm glad that you're
still here with us on this earth
if for a short time
um
so whatever um
whatever the universe this
whatever plan it has for you
that brought you close to death
to maybe enlighten you some kind of way
um
i think
i think he has a
has an interesting plan for you you're
one of the truly special humans and it's
a huge honor that you would sit and talk
with me today thank you so much thank
you very much alex i really appreciate
that thank you
thanks for listening to this
conversation with donald hoffman to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you with some words from
albert einstein relevant to the ideas
discussed in this conversation
time and space
are modes by which we think
and not conditions in which we live
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time